two
hello everybody it is Monday May
22.
we're here
Against All Odds
they said
we wouldn't dare show our faces again
and yet we still do every time oh I'm
being told this is actual this is actual
face I'm so sorry Ethan that's all right
I understand Iraq
whatever your name is welcome everybody
thanks for being here we got a great
week of shows here for you guys which is
a change for us obviously today's
episode is sponsored by PayPal honey
thank you so much to them
I'm feeling a little bit under the
weather
all the kids are sick nothing serious
just like a little throat cold
yeah but other than that feeling good we
gotta actually we're having a very
interesting calling today by none other
than Alex Weiss
AKA a dubs who was the subject of an
Olivia PowerPoint last week
which was what day was that on it was it
was Friday oh it's on Friday so this is
a fresh fresh stuff um
this is the
YouTuber who disappeared for four months
and then came back talking about a cult
she disappeared to Peru on some
Ayahuasca Journey
and our our PowerPoint concluded that
she may have joined a cult it sounded
pretty weird and so what happened was
did we reach out or did she reach out to
us
I think she might have dm'd us actually
yeah I believe she reached out to Olivia
Olivia's outside right now but I believe
she reached out to her so she reached
out to us interestingly in fact I think
she followed all of us on social
by the way I have noticed that she's
been wearing Teddy fresh so she is
she is family to some extent extended
family she may be in twofolds soon to be
soon to be a friend of the show whatever
I said you may be in two Cults that's
what I'm talking about can you be in two
Colts I feel like you got to pick a lane
that's true
me as this cult leader I say
I say uh
to other cults
so um
she's gonna call in at two o'clock
I'm gonna talk to her I'm gonna see
what's going on you know
uh
her fans were
I guess some of them were upset in that
fact that
she said she disappeared for four months
saw that everybody was worried about her
and made the conscious decision to
leave everybody hanging because she
thought it was juicy gossip or something
but um I guess that pissed off a lot of
her fans who are genuinely worried about
her leaving my friendships bomb thank
you
and
and then um
well then there's the whole cold aspect
so I am I have a lot of conversa uh
questions for her so I'm very much
looking forward to talking to her at 2PM
let the conversation that's what I say
that's what I always say
um
on uh Friday we went to Dave and Busters
busted down wheel Busters we busted that
[__] down so let's see how was it the
food was kind of fire at Dave and
Buster's it's pretty good I'm not even
gonna hate on it the nachos were
everything
boneless wings were rocking the boneless
wings were slapping hard that was Sam's
passion project is that right you
brought us an extra set home Sam for
later
I did
that's what's up
of course that's what's up you said for
in bed did you eat it in bed yeah oh my
God a wing uh on our sheets and there's
like a stamp of a wing
how's that how are you cool with that
Ian are you opposed to eating in the bed
your thoughts on that
uh I don't like how on the edge it is
like she plays with fire and it stresses
me out and I knew I knew it happened I
watched her drop it and she went
and I just knew I heard the sound and
I'm like there's a Wing on the bed we
have white sheets and white blankets
that's awesome but it is what it is you
know what I mean exactly exactly
sometimes you gotta bring the wings in
the bed everywhere we go to eat Sam will
have like two bites back I'm full and
I'm like you just want to eat it in bed
that's it I don't know what it is I love
eating in bed okay interesting so this
is a daily uh Occurrence at home yeah I
mean pretty much I usually eat like half
of my meal at the restaurant and then
I'm like I know what time it is you
consciously are you saving it
specifically to eating better are you
actually full no I'm saving it you're
saving it so you're on to her Ian yeah
she's like a dinner squirrel she just
Hoards it to bring back that's
interesting so what do you are you
watching TV in bed are you doing
something about are you just laying
there yeah I'll be watching TV or on
Tick Tock or something but there's just
something about it can I ask how big is
your guys's bed what size it's a queen
okay so it's big not huge it's not I'm I
want to upgrade to a King because so Ian
is he's forced to participate in this
whole thing because you guys will be
pretty close we'll order We'll order
food and it'll be delivered it'll be
like 8 p.m and then Sam will take it and
go to eat and I'm like I don't want to
go to bed right now let's eat at the
table that's awesome no eat in bed or
I'm going to bed now that's awesome wow
okay
interesting this is the inner workings
of a relationship
fantastic
well it sounds like you better either
convert you better get with it or you
better you know I mean if you can't beat
them join them Ian but those wings are
really good I would eat those in bed
they have the best wings I don't know
what it is Dave and Buster's wings
did you share the wings with Ian or were
those all for you I don't think you had
a knee no I wouldn't have shared them I
don't believe excellent
yeah but we had fun at Dave and busty's
we each got
everyone a card with like I don't
understand the system there you think it
would be tokens but they call it like
Buster bucks
no they don't what do they call it it
sounds like crypto let me see they have
the weirdest names
not it's not even credits it's not
credits no it's something even weirder
I don't think
but anyway I got whatever the currency
there is I got everybody 500.
and we must have been there for like two
or three hours and I didn't even get
close to spending all those credits boy
was anyone able to oh just chips by the
end of the night chips yeah yeah by the
end of the night we cleared out most of
the cars you did well we all kind of got
obsessed with it so
every arcade since I was a little kid
has these machines where it's like
a shelf that's slowly going forward and
backwards and there's coins all over it
yes and I've always seen those since I
was a little kid and never really
understood what it was supposed to be
and I was always more interested in the
arcade games anyway so I just always
ignored it well Ally was like oh no I'm
actually really good at this she was
locked in she and so she she started
playing that and we realized because you
know they have like tickets there that
if you got the the Chevy thing to knock
over all these cards that it has in
there if you get the full set it was
like crazy amount of tickets and sort of
like okay that seems like this is
actually the best you know credit per
ticket ratio game if you can do it
so Ali drained her card and then I and
then I think Zach drained his and then
Sam got caught up in it I got caught up
in it
um I added more money to mine you did
people saying it's a scam sorry not a
scam we [__] won we hit the [__]
jackpot on that made that machine all
right
okay so you guys probably spent like 500
at that machine by mine I added I added
35 more dollars oh my God but I got like
like [__] like six or seven of those
cards which I was pissed because like
when you go and redeem your prize like
take them away from you okay so actually
Zach I I got a bone to pick with you
because you jumped the gun a little bit
because you went in there
with your cards and then I hit the
freaking jackpot a few minutes later and
I had all of them but one and it was one
that you had so we would have had I
didn't I didn't the mega jackpot I was
exhausted oh wait it's not a big deal so
so
I just really wanted that thermostat
they had a [__] thermostat as one of
the prizes did you get anywhere close to
that no it was like it was like 150 000
tickets which was like 1200 bucks so
there's this funny thing we were in the
GIF area where you redeemed the tickets
before we went out so we could
strategize
and I was like we're gonna be able to
get something big with all of our powers
combined so there was a couple of funny
ones the funniest was this [__]
thermostat it was 150 000 chips yeah or
whatever why are they calling them chips
now it's like I don't know get real
um and then they said you can buy uh
tickets if you're close so you can put
in the money and get there and it was
like uh a dollar for 10 tickets
something yeah the ratio was pretty
awful and so and so it was a hundred and
fifty thousand or whatever it was yeah
it was 150 yeah and there was like a
switch for 120 000. yeah it was like
five thousand dollars
it was it was 10 tickets for one dollar
and it was 150 000 that'd be
uh fifteen thousand dollars no would it
really be I think the ratio is a little
bit better than that no we did the math
at the time it was like it was like 1200
bucks or something I mean it's still
loud and the thermostat was like the
thermostat at Dave and Buster's like
who's getting the thermostat I just
thought that was so [__] funny that
they even had that it was a 200
thermostat and the thing was I saw the
game you guys were playing the big
jackpot was 2500 tickets
yeah so you would only need to have win
that like
we were trying to run out of our car and
do like this big wheel that you spin and
so me and Lena were doing it with Ally
and then we're just having everyone that
passed by try it and Olivia's like oh
I'll try it and she goes oh I lost my
phone ran away and she hit the jackpot
didn't even realize I don't think we saw
it for the rest of the night you
disappeared I was pretty magic with it
yeah
yeah that I don't like the conversion uh
Factor at Dave and buckos there's one at
the even buckos at the Woodland Hills
Mall a similar type of place it's not
Dave and buckos it's a small one but the
conversion rate is crazy good really
like me and Teddy went there spent like
20 bucks and we came away with like all
kinds of good [__]
this is this is what I got with my
reward but are you serious that's pretty
good wait how many tickets you're pretty
good this was a lot this was uh
I think this was like 3 000 or something
that's that's dope though that's
actually a cool prize I brought home two
uh mugs you got too much yeah they're
really cool mugs that have like a game
controller handle
um it was a lot of fun okay thank you
again anyone else get any oh you're
welcome that was a really fun night
anyone else get anything of course we're
saving up for the Roomba the Roomba
right I think that one was uh 500 000.
okay I think it was like a hundred and
eighty thousand Jesus is great I had
tickets to spare and I gave it to Ian I
think I had like 500 left yeah I
pocketed those oh you did yeah so I
still I still got uh like 200 Buster
bucks in my car oh dude yeah yeah you
guys are just the generate gamblers I
was just playing let's go back let's go
let's go let me uh wrap up the show uh I
have a whole bunch left over I'm gonna
have to take Theodore and Bruce there
mm-hmm but we not we had so many tokens
we were played the whole goddamn Halo
shooting game oh yeah we beat it we beat
the whole [__] game the master chief
bro it was so sick dude you were killing
me the ending sucked too sounds like I
mean the whole game kind of sucked but I
don't know we had fun I mean if you're
gonna invest all that time and money I
wanna I want something a little spicier
that game was not that good there was
yeah and it was it was pretty flat yeah
I wanted more story I wanted more cut
scenes um maybe I was maybe a sex scene
I was just sexing thrown in there what
was that called it's like a pulp the
machine Halo uh I think it was called
raven Halo Raven Halo Raven Raven Raven
Ops or something and then by the way the
one game I really wanted to play which
was a Dance Dance Revolution they only
had one [__] machine and there's
always two weirdos there hogging it up
I put a link in the dock too when you
got screwed over trying to play with me
and Dan the racing game you had bad luck
that day that was some [__] dude we
were playing this racing game and we all
wanted to play together but for some
reason it would not let Ethan in so me
and Dan played like twice together so
sad racing by myself
stupid ass thing the card readers there
like every other game for me would
always [__] up here it wouldn't accept
it yeah there was a lot of busted ones
Dave and Busters this is what it was one
of the machines one of the guns was
broke
so right around the whole [__] Squad
I recruited a whole elite special or
forces Squad to go play the game and
then we get over there and poor cam
pick the the bad seat that didn't work
so he wasn't able to play with us that's
okay I still got BTS footage yeah here
we are
the boys we're having a ton of fun wait
no this is the racing game I got right
no this is what Amy was talking about
how you look how much fun they're having
they were having the time around they
were laughing and you know
joshing around and I was like man this
game's [__] boring what are you guys
doing over there but yeah I got a lot of
footage for behind the scenes this week
the arcade sad the saddest looking man
in the arcade right there you know the
funniest thing about the whole night
though was when we first got there and
we had a table for dinner
it was like the early bird special at
the retirement home there was like
you didn't notice there was another
party over near us and it was like 25
people and they were all like elderly I
was like what's going on like the
elderly like Meetup at the Dave and
Buster's was not what I didn't notice
that on a Friday night I saw them when I
saw like 30 old people walk in I'm like
we're never gonna [__] order no that
that was a that was like a mafia Meetup
there was a guy there that dressed like
Molly and David because we'll discuss
our business there that's that's the
family right there
yeah it was good though man and uh let's
see yeah it was really fun yeah Dave and
Buckaroo thank you again oh Ethan
covered it was very nice to you yeah
thank you very much we've got to mention
though you were like crooked that day
you were staying do you have a picture
of that yeah
crooked yeah I was getting a little
disturbed because you guys on Friday I
like [__] my neck up oh right it's
pretty much better now I was on a heat
pad all weekend but I'm not crooked now
right baby
look back no dude I thought I was
standing up straight and Lena took a
photo of me and I got freaked out
because I was like this is gonna damage
my back permanently
someone asked what's the BTS channel
it's this channel BTS goes up for
members every Friday
thank you you got that photo yeah
everyone was photoing me like a goddamn
clown
laughing at my dumbass
you know
oh here's Dan uh
Pro gaming at the quarter machine
or something wait
here's Dan Pro gaming
[Music]
this is the face Ally don't show this
look how close all the cars are look how
many cars there are and those all fell
dude so wait what did you buy then Dan
if you were there all night we got
three uh uh plushies you're the Aiden
Ross of the arcade I mean I didn't
really want anything I don't I don't
like stuff I don't wanna like I get the
tickets spend all this time getting
these tickets and I go in there I'm like
I don't want I don't want anything I
always go for candy like that AB did the
right how he wanted Ally wanted the
plushies so we got we got a bunch of
Mario plushies and actually the uh
extremely [__] stoned uh employee
um when he's checking out he like [__]
up or something and he like gave us all
the plushies and then I scanned my
cardigan to see what was left over and
he like didn't
he didn't take any of the [__]
tickets he like [__] it up something
dude my man was blown he was gone yeah
and so Ally was like uh oh let's go get
more and I'm like no we're not we're no
more plushies three plushies is enough
I'm with Ali you gotta you gotta get
what you can from there I really wanted
that switch I ended up I ended up buying
it the next day not from Dave and
Buster's but I got my hopes up and I was
like [__] [__] it oh you just went to a
store this one just talking about it
yeah it's probably a smarter way wait
you don't have a switch I do but I
wanted I hate the display on the other
one I got the you got the new upgraded
one the the OLED whatever it's called
you don't like the new one you went and
bought the old one no no the other way
around the old one yeah
I wanted to give my sister uh my switch
anyway so excuse I need it there it is
yeah that'd be kind of weird to go back
to Dave and Buster's and buy it from
them I want that five thousand dollars
right specifically did you pull up your
crooked photo here is me playing Pac-Man
by the way I got the top score so don't
be hating
and you bar witness for that great first
round yeah no you were cooking for sure
when we were giggling about the way you
were standing you would try to stand up
straighter and straighter but every time
you would do that you would get more and
more crooked and it was the fun you were
like what about now how about now how
about now
it was it was the most insane dilution
I've ever seen I loved it well hold on
do you have one of me trying to stand up
straight I don't know
Lena took a bunch of them but she's not
here uh he's out are you feeling better
now though yeah my neck feels a lot
better that's good yeah that's good I
was legit worried when I went home
though and then when I'm on my way home
this is an interesting story I'm on my
way home I'm at a red light
turns green
the guy next to me there's two lanes he
starts going faster than me
car a big van not it's a van it's a
family van you know runs the red light
T-Bones the duck car next to me damn
right in front of me it's scary
so I'm so what are you supposed to do
right you pull over and you stop so that
you can bear witness so I okay thanks
Cameron
thanks
yeah you see guys we said to do a quick
analysis yeah the analysis checks out
I'm glad we had the lines I couldn't
tell who was who was standing up
straight
um so I went I pulled over
and I go over back to the wreckage
and uh I go whose cars is who the guy in
the van who ran the red light caused the
accident he looks me in the face he goes
oh my God you're Ethan Klein
hey
I was like yeah but but which car is
yours he's like it's the van I was like
oh yeah you [__] up
he's like no he hit me I was like bro
you ran the red light and you you almost
hit me dude oh [__] was he drunk at all
no he seemed sober well if he was a fan
you could be like you know who to call
PMP let's go right that's true I should
have suggested that so I just went over
to the other guy I was like yo bro I
just want to let you know
you that was 100 the other dude's fault
I gave him my phone number
and I said if you need me to testify
anything text me
and I was like sorry bro
it's such a it's like a curb scene of
like
a fan you know having to rat out the fan
if he had like another thought I [__]
hate that dude Ethan man
he snitched on me in a car accident wait
you're not gonna help me out Ethan I'm a
big fan I'm a big fan I could have
helped him I could have helped him
well I could have been like are you a
fan or an old fan yeah he's like family
no I was like I got you bro it's his
fault I just lie because that dude's
fault
oh that's funny but actually I'm glad
that I did because they were um arguing
about whose fault it was so I was like
listen with peace and love
to my wonderful fan you ran that [__]
red light beautiful Harley
it would be epic if you saved a fallen
fan
but the other guy's a fallen fan but now
he's you've been redeemed no he that he
wasn't my demo the other guy got you I
was like when he was like yo ether
client I was like please be the please
be the guy that got hit please be the
guy that got hit
nope sorry
[__]
so that happened
it's exciting
also come somewhere interestingly Dan
was getting heckled out in public I saw
this post on the subreddit I heckled
this guy was utterly embarrassed
uh by his behavior in public Dan
I embarrassed myself by yelling W Dan at
the man himself yesterday I asked Dan if
this happened he confirmed it yeah no I
was getting you Dan I was getting my
gear ready to shoot some pictures of
boats in the beautiful California sea
lions who are heading into math mating
season
[Music]
as I was fumbling through my stuff I
heard in all too familiar voice I looked
up to my surprise I saw Wild Dan
approaching
I used just leave famous people alone
especially people with net worths like
dance what does that mean this means I'm
a broke [__] like you know I'm not you
know I only got the 10 million dollars
so what he only heckles people who are
rich yeah or could could just mean
because of your net worth on Google
not work yeah aren't you worth 10
million bucks or something like that
something I think it was just like a
million or something
congrats thank you thank you worked real
hard for them you're not a broke [__]
you're not it's not like oh that it's
not like Stevo during jackass era no no
Wayne
okay that's funny though and then he
says uh but this time regrettably
something within me was urging me to say
something quickly before he passed I
shouted all I could think of w Dan
was chilling wave the class act as
always but I immediately filled with the
overwhelming wave of cringe why would I
say that why wouldn't I leave him alone
I think the answer is clear I have
self-diagnosed undiagnosed Tourette's
we'll be joining Nexium finally to cure
myself I thought it was funny I don't
think it's funny yeah I don't know if he
was actually embarrassed if he was just
leaning into it for the sake of the
posts but it was a it was a very polite
totally normal interaction the post is
by baby without AIDS
here he says 75 ship post
but I did get a nice little henna cringe
so he's just go for himself
there it is baby with AIDS confirmed by
Dan this did take place
what did he look like
what do you look like just normal dude I
actually what I remember most about the
interaction was his camera uh
which I guess it makes sense he was out
there to shoot the sea lions or whatever
but he had what looked like a really
nice like vintage camera so uh shout out
to me and notice he's got fun out there
Dan noticed
yeah I was with my family and stuff we
had just gotten lunch and
uh it was
if anything it I don't think anybody's
ever uh recognized me out in public with
my parents so that was kind of cool hype
yeah so if anything I appreciate it dude
yeah did your parents say anything
yeah they were really confused at first
and like is that like a show thing does
he know you oh yeah it's too much to
explain but yes W Dan W Dan Ellie was
telling us this story yesterday when we
all hung out and she uh she mentioned
that someone recognized you on your
guys's first date
I don't know that's oh that's how shout
out to the it was it was two people they
were together and we were on our first
date at a coffee shop and we were
sitting out on the patio out front and
somebody walked by and was like yo Dan
that's awesome yeah
I think that was uh it was a plant it
was a plan yeah I joked about that at
the time I was like yeah I paid them so
slick Ben is so slow such a great
boyfriend Dan is
she's a lucky girl
it's a good man
and a passionate lover
it's true true
I would assume
[Music]
he's a passionate guy he cares about
things
um
yes Dan enters the room
had a couple drinks I'm not gonna do
that to you no please stop
um
yeah it was fun I enjoy spending the
time with you guys love all you guys
yeah I love you guys we're watching the
Celtics with Cam too we were rooting for
the uh oh man Austin bro I've never seen
cam mad before dude I I taunted him a
little bit because I I don't I'm not
into basketball I don't care but
obviously the Celtics and the Lakers
have like a big thing and I grew up here
uh and he grew up in Boston so I had to
make kind of like a snide comment at him
and he [__] cam snapped at me he's
[__] pissed he was like he told me he
told me to shut up one time because I
was talking so shut up they're [__]
playing the run right now you guys are
over exaggerating this I did I did I was
in the moment I was trying to pay
attention and yeah come on someone new
pushing my buttons I don't know yeah he
was pushing your button no you're good
yeah no it's fine but I was with Boston
all the way I thought they had at cam I
love dude your energy was revitalizing
my spirit too even though they lost I
was very happy that you were I thought
they had it bro yeah I appreciate it
they did not have it and they're down
what a shitty to lose man they were so
close and then it all just fell apart in
the last five minutes Jimmy Butler did
Jimmy Butler Ethan was like Boston's the
they're the green guys right yeah
Green is cool I like green yeah sure
Celtics and seven thank you
[Music]
so um
also uh this was on the subreddit and I
don't know what we were waiting for
something represent was supposed to like
redesign their website and they never
did so we never announced it but we were
waiting for something but because
they're just not doing it
this amazing design is up on represent
now with all the uh the busts the busts
so awesome such a cool design
this was by uh the artist shared it
this is her
we love you thank you we appreciate it
such great art
so if you guys want to um
you guys want to purchase this awesome
design head over to what's it
h3freeshop.com that's right
that's right that's easy there's a
there's a few more products that are
going to be added so we've just been
doing a lot of back and forth with
proofs and I wanted to announce it all
at one time but
um there's just a lot of uh notes and
going back and forth so they'll be up oh
this is another one we haven't announced
this one's also crazy
this is the
front this is the back the design is
super cool
love that peace and love this is a
serious message to everybody watching
you think it'd be a problem if I put
Ringo's face on merch that's legal right
I don't think the Beatles are litigious
no
I'm warning you with peace and love I
have too much to do
yeah probably not the best idea oh my
throat is super [__] up
uh yeah
so anyway
um
oh one other little fun thing Mr Beast
we talked about his curing blindness
this man changed the thumbnail again
this [__] it cracks me up man he and he
I love that he's changing the ethnicity
this one is the worst one by like a lot
right do we all agree on that like that
is like something really disturbing
about the kid it's uncanny yeah face the
shape it just doesn't look right on the
body and I hate this one it looks like
he stole his hearing yeah
but who knows maybe
um people are clicking for it I don't
know maybe I to me this is by far the
worst that he's thrown up yeah he's like
do you want this yellow idiot okay
hate that dumb idiot you're short you're
short can't reach it can't reach it
yeah but uh
I was bullied yeah the the last one was
Hispanic I think and then he just went
like well
keep on cloaking for the Hispanic code
so let's just go with the white kid
with the weird shaped hat oh well he's a
real kid we love him
I think he [__] it up it looks they
got a generated or something yeah maybe
so that's what I'm saying maybe he's not
a real kid I hate those [__] tears
dude
I think it's a crying milk yeah what the
[__] disturbing I think it may be AI
generated because the other kid the
initial one looks like an older version
of this kid so
um
yeah I think you might be right it just
doesn't look right
it's Mr B's clones well they don't just
Jimmy little Jimmy I mean they don't
have like a kid Factory for thumbnails
where they just cycle in I think they do
I think they've come that far he did buy
that whole neighborhood yeah
neighborhood okay if you're gonna live
in this house you're gonna have to bring
your son over
3 P.M
every night
and I'm gonna take a bunch of screen
photos of it you cannot be present in
the room
no no adult can be present in the room
just me and your son 30 minutes
I will get you when we're done
don't forget me I will get you
and then you can you can live in the
house for free and free
Mr Beast does that actually
[Music]
but not this one we're just kidding this
one is this in this case we're dead
serious deadly serious this is one of
the few times I'm just totally serious
[Laughter]
I'm dead seriously nah but uh
I look forward to the um hopefully
there'll be like a black kid in the
future one and we'll see of us to click
right through right click through rate
on that when it does have 71 million
views so maybe I think that's low for
him I think he's actually really
concerned with the viewership on this uh
oh
falling off oh Mr Beast uh oh yeah cause
this video is usually get like 100
million well it's only been two weeks
they get 100 million like that fast yeah
they do yeah dude I mean here he's not
helping the video [__] ass which it
does yeah cause look at that's what I
think too you're right no it's doing
horrible and I hate to say but like
he was super excited about this one too
he was hyping this is the best video
they've ever done 8 000 hours of editing
which I just don't know why he thought
that it makes me it makes me question do
you think he knew it was bad and he was
just doing that to try and like no I
make it not a flop if he thinks it's not
bad he doesn't post them he does that
all the time yeah dude they need to have
a town hall meeting and figure this [__]
out
right do you guys know that he pays five
to ten thousand dollars per thumbnail
too he says what now he pays five to ten
thousand dollars per thumbnail how do
you know that he said it on a podcast
Pace Hill yeah he's a thumbnail he
doesn't have an employee that does it I
I don't know does he have like a whole
team in the laboratory full of graphic
designers I guess he can do it if
anybody can I just dropped you paid ten
thousand for this
Mr Beast does talk about how important
the thumbnail is and he you know the
amount of money that he makes off these
videos I guess
if it really is that critical of a part
of it just says I get that but I just
don't see the need to spend that money I
mean here this one has 160 million after
one month yeah
so yeah this is this one's tanky man
sorry Beast
don't lose Faith man what what did the
blind one get
the blind one did really good 140. 140.
yeah 141 after three months
I'm in that plane ticket one has 160
after only people don't care about
helping the needy man [__] them right
right
show me what a [__] expensive show me
what happens when you crush a
Lamborghini and hydraulic press brother
that's what I want
some kids
there was one he did uh
do the squid games one do you see that
423 million yeah that one was a special
very special circumstance with all the
hype around the show and everything
though I'm glad it paid off because it
did look like he spent so much money on
that one yeah oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah brother
um but there it is Mr Beast he's out
there you know everyone has their bad
days
oh hell yeah brother I also you know
that's like one of the only thumbnails
without him in it
it's an interesting choice to not put
himself in it right oh see that that
could explain because this is just like
did the older ones have it yeah they all
did in the other ones this one doesn't
maybe he found it embarrassing how a few
views it's getting so he took him his
face off of it I didn't eat for 30 days
that one flopped big time actually yeah
that one's a big old flop dude however
like it's a flop it has it only has 90s
that's embarrassing frankly
I guess I guess he has some stinkers and
and I can't all be bangers but you're
right it is odd how how like confident
he was with this one in particular and
it is so because I I watch all of his
videos this was my least favorite in a
long time yeah I just found the whole
thing very odd
also one thing you should take into
account uh Jimmy if you're watching
which I'm sure you are watch time makes
a huge difference you know that I don't
know why you edited it to be so short
six minutes if it was 12 minutes long I
guarantee you would have double the
views guarantee
you could pay you could send me my
million dollar check for that advice
right
so he actually has another Channel
called Beast philanthropy and he did
this video called I helped 2000 amputees
walk too whoa that's a funny thumbnail
for that too hold the phone and I just
went to check on it and they have been
changing thumbnail on that one too I
wish I documented it so the thing is he
yeah you can see the real-time
click-through rate so I think he's just
you know he's all about the stats and
stuff so he's he's in there
I helped 2000 amputees walk again all
right show me what you got
um
does he call you watch a minute no it's
fine to watch it but um we should do our
ad and uh because our guest is gonna be
calling in and about okay
let's see
this make me cry because the pressure
for her
what's he doing for him I guess I should
watch it instead of just clicking
through
available on Android and yeah dude
this walking is brought to you by you
can play in the classic four player [__]
yeah dude a 12 player Survivor this is
everything competition hey I've never
hey I just learned to walk what's going
on here
put me between your legs
uh
uh we kid Jimmy but we love him
we kid the ones we love
all right let me thank our wonderful
sponsor honey
let's do it I'll be I'll be straight up
with you guys I don't watch a lot of
YouTube I watch every Mr Beast video
I do don't watch a lot of YouTube huh
not like traditional I I find myself
watching more like
political [__] like David Pac-Man and
Sam Cedar
that's YouTube [__] I guess so
you're just an old old man you're an old
man no man anyway honey we love honey
man
and thank you for being such a great
supporter of the show
right there's a reason to go click that
link and install the extension
but the other reason is
just makes sense
yeah that today's episode is sponsored
by PayPal honey the easy way to save
When shopping on your iPhone or computer
it's incredible
the amount of money I've saved and Ila
saved with this
browser extension also available on
mobile phones now
you go to your favorite website
the amount of websites that this works
on
is endless
talking food I'm talking gadgets I'm
talking clothes everything all different
flavors of websites
as you're checking out
like you do at checkout
a button appears
it says do you want me to find
the best coupons possible for this
website obviously yes you click the
button five seconds later it presents
you with the best coupon savings
automatically scouring the website for
you automatically applies it look these
are all real savings that have happened
of mine and elas
12 bucks saved there you don't even have
to think about it dude 21 bucks saved
there
and it's got one of these codes you know
that I would never like pattern 15 what
the [__] is that I don't know what that
is but they do honey knows
it's no brainer I mean there's no
downside to having this installed and I
I don't use the internet without it this
look at this 135 dollars
imagine you're shopping at one of your
favorite sites when you check out the
honey button appears and all you have to
do is Click apply coupon
wait a few seconds as honey searches for
coupons you can find for that site and
if honey finds a working coupon you'll
watch the price drop
also exciting honey doesn't just work on
desktops it also works on your iPhone
now just activate it on Safari on your
phone and save on the go
so if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out on free
money I mean literally and by getting it
you'll be doing your self-assault and
supporting the show thank you so I'll
get PayPal honey for free at
joinhoney.com
h3tv that's joinhoney.com h3tv thank you
guys so much and thank you to honey
perfect battery well done thank you
I need like a hot beverage my throat is
killing me dude
uh what should I do is coffee bad for a
hotter over yeah probably I would
irritate it more but then why why does
some coffee irritate more than tea
I don't trust you at GPT since when
since the last few days I don't know I'm
kind of turned on it
she's been reading more about it and I
realized that you know what chat GPT is
chat should be tea
the world's greatest bullshitter that's
not true it's the world all it does is
make you think it sounds like it knows
what it's talking about it's like the
ultimate Reddit poster that's just not
it's a confident Reddit poster it's just
not true
it's facts I'm just speaking it knows
everything how can it [__] if it
knows everything no it knows what you
want to get here
I want to hear man you know why you know
why you're hating why because you asked
chat gbt if there's evidence that diet
soda is bad for your health and it said
there is no evidence
um damn
[Music]
it
you read that hurts and just look at Dan
when you read it
tea is often considered soothing for the
throat while coffee is not due to
several factors temperature hot tea can
provide warmth coffee pot which can help
alleviate discomfort and reduce
inflammation hydration
wait hold on on the other hand coffee is
often consumed hot which can potentially
irritate and already sore throat what
the [__] does that mean that's
contradictory
hot tea is is warming and but then
coffee is hot and it irritates
ask this why does coffee irritate why
does hot coffee irritate but not hot tea
so let's make it justify itself Dan
[Music]
we'll see maybe I'll agree with you
after this very interesting
that's [__]
uh many types of teas such as herbal
teas or warm water with honey and lemon
can help keep your throat hydrated
what about coffee oh wait wait I
apologize for the complete confusion in
my previous response I made an error in
my statement both hot tea and coffee can
potentially irritate the throat if it is
already a sensitive if it is already
sensitive or inflamed
uh uh that's not what it said what the
[__] wrong with that thing it said hot
tea can provide warmth to the throat
which can help alleviate discomfort and
reduce inflammation what happened it
doesn't happen you blew it it says the
main follower that can do different oh
my God I can't say this word
can someone help me differentiate it if
I can't say it differential
differentiate
it
says
differentiate yeah yeah uh the effects
of hot tea and coffee on the throat is
their acidity
so say so say this is hot coffee okay to
drink when you have a sore throat
you know what I mean
basically I want coffee Alex is in the
uh waiting room
just a heads up I just want to get this
beverage situation resolved you know
before we start talking are you on the
main account I'm not seeing the question
that you're asking I'm logged in
[Music]
which is probably why it made that
mistake when you have a sore throat yeah
I think I'm about 3.5 oh you fool no I
don't think that matters for the log oh
previous questions no he's on his own
account he doesn't have access do you
have Ayahuasca tea uh perhaps yeah
that'd be a good setup for this can I do
we have I think we have throat coat we
don't have Ayahuasca we do have we do
have some DMT would you like to smoke
some of that really quickly this call
dude I want some coat with some throat
coat
poker doesn't sound vulgar I need
somebody to coat my throat yeah I have
menthols those are good for the throat
oh I'll just leave a nice little coating
doc doctors approved yeah dude I haven't
had a single cigarette and it's got to
be a year
good for you man not a single one
ah a year I think so I can't remember
the last time it's been a long time okay
okay maybe close to yeah
I mean when's the last time I spoke with
you Zach
um it's been a minute I noticed that on
Friday when me and Zach walked outside
of smoke and you didn't join us I was
like it's been a while
it's been a while I'm doing good also
this morning weighed in
at 2 10. let's go very much
I have a photo that I sent ELO I'll tell
you the exact way
Dan should mail up that Dome
what's up are you ready bro I'm ready
bro you should mail up that Dome I am
red day it's 210.4
the real deal
and by the way I stepped way far away
from the scale because I was butt ass
naked when I took the photo and I wasn't
gonna be that guy who's dead little dick
you could see the reflection of the
scale where he's like [__] how do I
delete this
that wasn't gonna happen to me boy I
tell you
good thinking Dan get that Mayo
somebody else has to get the mail I draw
the line I'm purchasing get that Mayo
all right so Alex is on so let's go
ahead and bring on Alex this is uh okay
a dubs is there a YouTube name and Alex
Weiss
uh is her is her a government name
that's right
I wonder what's her Ayahuasca name
hey Alice yes thank you for joining us
nice to chat with you obviously
a lot of people are have a lot of
questions
I've answered okay that's exciting
um first of all
nice to see you wearing Teddy fresh
that's that's appreciated
I'm a fan that's awesome thank you yeah
and um
so essentially uh correct me if I've got
the this facts wrong I'll just kind of
establish the situation here a little
bit all right let's do it so Alex Weiss
uh a dubs
is uh making regular content uh
how frequently are you posting uh back
before you left
more or less once a week for like 14
years and then okay
and then I was doing a podcast every
week for about six months okay so there
was great regularity
yeah so when you just suddenly
disappeared for four and a half months
on April 30th thank you so much Shredder
dang Joe
okay sorry I'm getting my throat coat
ready to go here so when you disappeared
uh for four and a half months
uh your fans started to get
understandably worried especially
considering the context of your last
video in which you talked about
meeting and escaping a cult yeah and
then also mentioning that you were going
to go do a potluck with them and then
from that you went dark
so let me start so that's all correct
right yeah okay yeah so let me start
here was this mention of a cult
was this and
was this an intentional thing that you
did to try to antagonize your audience
Okay so
me explain
so uh I know you were debating whether I
did it on purpose or I was sort of like
Saving Face after the fact
um so I was I was making this podcast
and
I heard that it was going to be canceled
along with a bunch of other shows people
were getting fired
um but I wasn't really supposed to know
it was a very toxic work environment
that I was in and uh so I went into my
last episode pretending that I didn't
know it was gonna be my last episode
completely coincidentally the night
before I went to a meditation group on
Meetup and
um it was it was culty I didn't even get
into the room because the outside of the
scenario was so sketchy to me
um and then
um I obviously was going to tell that
story on the podcast no matter what
because it's fascinating but there's a
part of me that kind of knew it would be
my last episode so it might be like an
interesting little something to throw
into Peak curiosity
um the I have done a lot of like
trolling type uh
rank videos on my channel before and so
for me it felt like a bit
and I also never planned on being gone
as long as I was gone I thought it would
be like a month tops
and so while this is definitely it feels
naive to say now I had I was not
thinking about the fact that people
would be worried
yeah and so um well what was this what
was this network uh you were part of of
these canceled podcasts
um they don't they don't
have a shin uh
uh I feel weird talking about it their
name is cast
they okay
yeah yeah I've heard of them I'm not
super familiar but I've heard that name
it was um it was part of the reason I I
would say I completely went black on the
internet was like so I talked about this
in my video
um at the beginning I don't think you
guys covered it was just talking about
workaholism
um and for me that was like the the end
of the road like I couldn't I couldn't
push myself any further I I was
like trying to keep my head above water
being a part of this company like they
weren't paying me it was just really
challenging
um and so uh when I finally got the out
from the podcast I just had to sort of
like take care of myself so I'm confused
I I I'm not part of like a network so I
don't know how this stuff works you're
an employee of cast or did you have a
show with them and did they would like
have you run ads and then pay you part
of that they were the production company
for the podcast so it was I guess that
you would say I was freelancing I was I
was making a show with them for them uh
and they were uploading it on other
platforms and then I was putting it we
were putting it on YouTube as well
yeah and so they were paying you like a
monthly thing they just they didn't pay
you they still haven't that's [__] up
it was also part of the reason I didn't
know when to come back because a lot of
my viewers didn't like the show and like
and neither did I and I wanted to talk
about that but I was it was suggested to
me that they would make me sign an NDA
um so I just didn't really know what to
say
so you didn't know what to say okay well
first of all [__] cast dude we gotta we
gotta get you paid dude
I am not the only one wait Hassan can I
say that to you I didn't know that uh
it's coming from the chat a few people
have said people in chat are saying
Hassan got burned by cast what is the
deal with these cast people I I don't
know hmm
I don't know
um I don't like these people that's true
I am just taking the chat's word for it
which
so you knew that this was coming down
the line how far ahead of time did you
know that the podcast was going to be
canceled
I think I found out either the day
before or two days before it was all
like a whirlwind okay yeah did they give
you a reason
uh not not particularly I mean in like
one fail swoop they fired like a ton of
people and then canceled a bunch of
shows the communication was okay not
great okay and so then
how far in between the show being
canceled did you I guess travel to the
Ayahuasca retreat okay well before I
tell you that I want to clarify me
um having that run in with a call in Los
Angeles I never went to the potluck I I
joked about it and I talked to a friend
about going and we were like this is a
bad idea we're not doing this
um the Ayahuasca Retreat so so unrelated
so the cult you mentioned totally
unrelated so unrelated I I have made
this huge mistake and like
it's crazy to find myself in this
situation but I realized that like I
basically planted two seeds next to each
other in the same video where I was like
I don't this was the rumor I dealt with
uh having this run in and now I'm going
to talk about this spiritual sort of
experience I had and obviously there's a
lot of crossover between Cults and
spiritual experiences and communities
um so I like I kind of feel like I
created this convoluted conversation
yeah I can see where the confusion came
from on that yeah okay so let's put
aside the cult you mentioned in your
last episode because uh
because that's unrelated although you
felt that was culty you referred to the
new one that you went to as cultish
though you joked about it
I think for me I was like trying to
segue in that video from the rumor and
from what I was actually doing and it
was just sort of a natural segue of like
some people might think this is culty
and here's the thing even if I didn't
plant those two seeds together surely
people would think this is culti because
um it involves a lot of kind of like out
there practices right that's yeah I mean
they're okay so
the show ends we're forgetting about the
weird uh cult here so how did you find
out about this Ayahuasca Journey
I would say in in September maybe like
two months before all this happened I
flew to Peru for one week to go to try
Ayahuasca at a center
um just sheer curiosity and it had
helped me so much that I continued to
start learning more
um about Ayahuasca and different plant
medicines and so uh once the show was
canceled and I knew I was going to take
some time off it was just sort of a
no-brainer that that's what I wanted to
go to go do with my time
um if you
huh but you find it odd though to like
just not say anything to your fans
who've been watching it weekly for 14
years
um yeah I and I definitely like I don't
like the way I handled it and I like
like truly am to my viewers sorry that I
completely left them in the dark I think
for me it was
when I left
really shortly after for Peru I didn't
expect to be gone that long and I I it
was kind of like planning on coming back
within a month
um but it was like the longer I was gone
the more debilitating it felt to come
back and say something and I was going
through such a weird experience
um that was very
like emotional I guess that I just I
didn't I wasn't in a place to say
something and I I tried like I and my
video I showed multiple clips of me like
attempting to film videos once I got
home it's like trying to word out social
posts it was like
it's it's like I couldn't move past the
this barrier
I I understand what you mean where it's
like you plan to be gone for a week and
then you kind of get wrapped up in this
whole thing and it becomes harder to
talk about I can't understand that
so
you went to uh it's this place in Peru
is it the my knitty Healing Center is
that the one you went to
I'm not gonna say what the center is I
just really don't want to drag them into
the situation okay fair enough I mean I
know there's probably a few of them out
there in Peru right they're somewhat
common tourist destinations probably
like some in the maybe like a hundred
more I would say okay yeah definitely
like an active business there okay yeah
so you arrive at this uh
this Healing Center or you had been
there before but you went back there no
different different oh a different one
okay I went to a different Center I
found it to be I had a great experience
but I found it to be very like
westernized very transactional so when I
chose the the next place that I went to
um I wanted it to be more authentic it
was just looking for a different
experience
um but also you know you can go and you
can do Ayahuasca but if you want to take
it a step deeper
um they'll put you on a thing called the
master plant Yeta so like so that's what
I was up to and that's why I was there
for for five weeks
and so one thing that I guess there's a
few things that made me thinking like
hmm this sounds kind of cold to you yeah
one you mentioned this guy Maestro that
sounds like [__] kind of gnarly Okay
so
it's a Maestra it's a woman okay Maestra
also it's sort of like it's sort of like
laughing at calling like a cup a cup
like it's simply like what they're
called it's like it means teacher in
Spanish so if you go to any
properly LED ayahuasca ceremony the
person leading it is going to be called
a maester or a shaman she also has a
name but the reason I didn't say it in
the video and I kept saying my extra
which I understand is kind of odd to
hear
um is because I just didn't want to like
drag the center specifically into it it
was the context which you brought it up
you were like uh you were joking about
uh wearing a cult and Colts usually have
like a strong central person and oh we
love them we love Maestra uh you kind of
brought it up in that context which is
which is true I mean I really I I do I
like I really adore this woman and she
did a lot for me but in that same
sentence I was saying that we have like
a reverence was what I was saying for
the plants we worked with too and I
would say like the plants are sort of
like the primary
uh like
Factor beneath all of this you know like
she helps
but it's about the plants are you still
in touch with anyone back from The
Retreat you went to
yeah I mean I I made a lot of friends
there so we we communicate and is there
any plans to return there
oh I want to film a a docu-series there
so yeah a docu-series okay which by the
way was my idea no no one encouraged me
I don't know you know these people have
powers of persuasion you know they plant
an idea in your head and you you think
it's yours so you want to go film this
place
yeah I'm I mean I think that there is a
lot to explore in general around like
indigenous cultures and what they can
teach us and I think this place
specifically is just sort of a like a a
screen a snapshot in that would be
really fascinating
here's a few things that
people noticed that I thought was pretty
interesting for example you're in an
isolation room I'm in isolation which
sounds weird already I mean
but okay but let me show you this detail
and then you can respond to it okay so
people pointed out if you yeah there's a
lock on the outside of the door that's
pretty strange
that's how you keep a prisoner
right I was never locked I don't think
that lock was actually on the outside I
mean I'm no it is
here let's watch slowly so you walk yeah
here's the door front of the door you go
in you shut there's the lock you can see
the lock you push it
I don't know into the room right here
see there's the lock 12 and then you're
in the room yeah I see it but I I don't
like I was never locked in that room I
don't I don't even remember like using
that that lock specifically
was there a lock on the inside
I thought that's what that lock was I
just never used it so I don't I don't
know like this seeing this for the first
time I'm like what is going on
um I was I was never locked in that room
so but wait I do want to say I do want
to say something if you look up Master
plant dietas which is like an indigenous
practice that they do in in many
different
um communities along the Amazon
isolation is like a huge part of it
it's a it's about kind of like getting
as quiet as you can so when things come
up you can you can process them okay
another thing I wanted to ask you about
is that we also noticed that you have
the same uh tattoo as your as your
mysterious friend you came back with
which everyone thought was kind of funny
that like you just came back with this
random bestie what does it say irake uh
Iraqi it means thank you in shapibo okay
did anyone else there have this tattoo
I left the center
um this wasn't planned but I just made
some good friends and we stayed in Peru
for a little longer and about
uh three other people we all got it
together I mean the thing is like we
went through a very transformative
experience together and we just we we
wanted to get that tattoo okay nobody
told you were they all from the United
States or the friends you made uh Canada
the United States obviously my friend
Tesla's from the UK
um from Denmark
I see an array so let's see so you were
there you were there for what like four
months though how long were you actually
at the retreat I was at the retreat for
five weeks and then I stayed in Peru for
I think three more weeks and then the
rest of it was just coming home and then
kind of like once I started
seeing how serious the cult rumor was
getting I I was just like debilitated
and coming back I didn't know what to
say I didn't know how to say it and I
was
um like going through a lot of
just like processing there's this period
after you do Ayahuasca or like any plant
medicine it's integration where like you
kind of have to change your life a
little bit to match the lessons you've
learned and so it was just like a very
intense period for me and I wasn't
I wasn't ready to get anything in your
comeback video you kind of trivialized
trivialized it though you said something
about how you thought it was just a
funny bit and I guess a lot of or a lot
of your fans thought that was
insensitive is that what happened yeah I
mean it the way I said it after uh in
that video after leaving them hanging
was insensitive the truth was like when
I said it was funny it was while I was
in Peru I wasn't on social media or
anything but I did get texts from from
two friends telling me that this was
happening in in a group chat and I
um when I said like it was funny it was
it was like this is so surreal I can't
believe this is happening and I'm so far
removed from this right now that I have
to like put it away for now and I'll
address it when I get home
um I also talked about how there was
this like sick satisfaction I guess that
that there was something to come back to
um when I was making that YouTube video
I really wanted to come at it from a
place of like complete honesty and so in
that video I talked about workaholic ISM
and that thought was like a function or
like a symptom of workaholism it wasn't
my driving
force or thought but it was something
that I I brought up and um it was
definitely like hard to watch back on
the show when you guys were talking
about it so well I guess you said you it
made you feel good in a way that you had
something to come back to I'm just kind
of curious to unpack that a little bit
so it was like you had something to come
back to as in like people are thinking
about you or you have a video to make to
explain it like what was it that you
meant by that
creatively
dry for so long
um that it was it wasn't about people
worrying or like wanting attention I
didn't it's not that I wanted people to
worry it was literally like oh this is
like a a concept it's something I can
like
tangibly make something of
um and and there was comfort in that and
it's like and I said it in the video I
don't I think you guys were talking over
it in the moment like I'm not proud of
the thought the fact that I had that
thought
um but I was in that video just trying
to like share everything that was coming
up for me
that makes sense that's fair and so
yeah
I I see I think the big uh disconnect
was the cult
mention in your last video that ended up
being totally unrelated to anything
yeah it I don't know how great of a job
I did in the video separating the two
um
I didn't I didn't expect all of this I
will say
so
so you're okay
you don't you don't feel that you're
part of a cold or any uh dangerous
situation
I don't and even the people in my life
were all like this is so crazy what's
happening and it's it's funny like
um I would say like the least okay I
don't I don't understand why you didn't
make that clear instead of playing up
like the oh I am in a am I in a cold or
am I not Nicole I mean I feel like in
the video I did I was joking about it
and I should have been more serious but
I was I was saying like this is what
happened
um now that I touched the fact that I
never got involved with this call here's
actually where I was right because it's
inherently spiritual some people might
mistake the two but I um
I should have made it clearer my
intention was not for people to then
think that I really wasn't a call like
the the bit was supposed to be over
right would you go to that potluck now
if you were invited I hear it's
happening again this weekend
um I think I probably passed you'd pass
okay you passed that test so tell I'm
actually just curious now your
experience there so you were there for
five weeks and then how soon after you
arrived you take the ayahuasca
I think it's the day after you have a
ceremony where you drink a really small
amount like you kind of barely feel it
just kind of uh right yeah
and um so I'm gonna explain I'm gonna
explain what it is but I know it's gonna
sound really out there
um the idea is that you can work with
different plants to heal various
different ailments physical spiritual
mental
um so when you're in that room with the
shamans who work there
um they kind of tap into your energy and
they can tell you what plants they think
you should work with and uh so every
single person there gets prescribed
different plants they'll be like you're
gonna drink this
um six days in a row and that's why we
fast sometimes is that you want those
plants like just like when drinking
alcohol it penetrates more if you're on
an empty stomach
um and and that's going to help you with
this X Y and Z and people come for
various different things
um so the first night you're testing it
a little bit they make you a special
formulation
and then uh was was there puking and
[__] the first night
not the first night
um at least not for me but there was a
decent amount of that in the weeks to
follow and did you ever [__] yourself
I never [__] myself but I definitely
um [__] yes that's fair I you know what
I mean we all poop you know it's
fascinating there are actually lots of
different kinds of purges like I did a
lot of yawning okay interesting so
did you ever have a close call did
anyone there [__] their pants
that's a great question I have a friend
that almost [__] their pants I would say
like close call in the brink of time
they made it to the bathroom
come on Zach it's got to be kind of
trippy to be like on Ayahuasca and
taking a massive dump in a tiny space in
like the jungle
it's the locks on the outside
yeah
so then um let's see here
tell me about you said so you got how
many people were at the ceremony doing
Ayahuasca with you
The Retreat holds about I want to say
maybe 19 people at a time but and they
they host three ceremonies a week but
you're not necessarily in a ceremony if
you're at the center because if you're
working with a different
non-psychoactive plant they don't have
you do both
um so you know probably as little as six
people as many as 19 people oh wow yeah
you feel when there's 19 people there
that it dampened your experience it can
be uh over stimulating especially if a
lot of people are puking the
that's kind of gnarly they should live
you want to go Olivia
well I mean I I'm identifying with you
Alex hey how are you hi
Olivia has a has a phobia of puke and
she was just saying actually that she
wanted she was considering going to the
Iowa well here's what I'm saying is that
if it's not a cult
um maybe you'll get over it well Alex
you said that you don't like it right so
you dealt with it well who likes does
anyone like puking I don't have like a
fear of it I would say actually I and it
was maybe one of the the less
uncomfortable parts of being on
Ayahuasca okay so I will absolutely not
be going thank you
for sure so is there people puking like
just on the floor and [__] or do are
they able to get it in buckets like
what's happening you have a little
in the bucket
no there's a bathroom there's a bathroom
nearby you can like kind of call a
facilitator a facilitator to come help
you walk to the bathroom is it close
yeah it's really close okay that's good
yeah so you could hear people like like
blasting ass okay so
during the ceremonies they're singing
this music it's called ikaros it's
medicine music
um and so you can't hear people blasting
ass during ceremonies okay
um but once the ceremonies end and
that's another reason it's hard to have
a lot of people in the ceremony because
it means it lasts to like I don't three
or four in the morning because
everyone's getting their own song
um after yeah if when everyone's like
kind of laying it's called in a maloka
the building
um you yeah and people have heard me
um get sick too it's just I feel like
they're doing a little bit I feel like
they're prioritizing profit over
experience if they're [__] if they're
slamming 19 bodies in there you know
what I mean it's a it's actually a
pretty big building like it never it
never felt I know but why you gotta hear
all these people puking and [__] like
six makes sense you know what I mean 19
like come on
no it it I mean I suppose I suppose it
is a lot it
it her
too much I think okay it was uh the
Maestro or anybody that works there get
the same tattoo as you do they have the
same tattoo no okay just checking
foreign
so you're there you're shooting your
brains out and then the next night you
take like a a bigger dose is that what
happens
the next night
um
be two to four nights later unless she
doesn't tell you to take Ayahuasca
because like for example I worked with
other plants so I drank this plant
called waiusa for six days and I wasn't
taking Ayahuasca
um tea it's not it's not a psychedelic
at all but when you're getting your body
quiet enough and so you're like not
consuming a lot or maybe you're in
isolation or your diet's really clean
I know this sounds crazy but somehow
you're able to sort of learn lessons
um whether it's your dream state or like
your waking days
is the herbal drink you're drinking I
know it's not psychoactive but it does
have some kind of like uh
property drug like property maybe a
sedative or
no no effect interesting yeah and who's
the lady sucking the puke out of you
guys
that's the the Maestra who runs the
center okay and how old is she
she's actually pretty young
um I think she's in her
30s and so as you guys are tripping
she's sucking on you and puking
I mean 19 people not not often I I would
say like this is an experience that not
everyone had and I had once during my
five weeks there it's also something
that like in hindsight I feel like maybe
I could have not shared on the Internet
it's like you kind of had to worry about
radical honesty yeah it sounds crazy
though and I know that and I think I
think if I could liken it to anything I
don't know much about this it's like
Reiki like it's she's doing energy work
of sorts all I know is she she sucked I
got up and and I felt different and I
and I thought it's crazy too but
it was my experience so how how intense
was her sucking how deep in did she
inhale was there more than one suck was
it a sucking moment it was uh just a
Sakira Sakira a Sakira okay okay
I don't know there's um it's hard to
really
when you're on Ayahuasca it's you know
girl
I know it's a heavy psychedelic so I'm
with you all the way I know this sounds
this sounds great
magic well was it euphoric well hold on
Olivia before you start you know it was
it euphoric before did you feel good to
Peru okay I would say so the first half
of my time there the Ayahuasca
ceremonies were [__] brutal
um because you're processing so much
stuff you're purging
um I would say I felt like fear
disorientation
um all the bad stuff and then the more I
worked through things the more kind of
like uh beautiful the ceremonies began
to become like they were about Oneness
and understanding your own power stuff
that that feels much better than the the
initial but did you have a body Euphoria
you know what I mean like when you
there's certain drugs that give you like
a body Euphoria I'd say Mushrooms do
that I you know painkillers do that a
lot of drugs do that ecstasy does that
you know what I mean
the experience is different so I will
say
what it doesn't mean that it would be
the same
um for me I would I actually experience
a lot of pain in my body more than
anything like it felt uncomfortable to
be in my body yeah
um and then if it wasn't pain I was just
completely not in my body like it was
experiencing like
um
what it felt like to not be Associated
to your mind or your body like you're in
some sort of like spiritual ego death I
believe we call that yeah is that what
we call it you're the resident acid uh
trip are you asking me uh sure yes yeah
as often times referred to that when it
comes to psychedelics thank you
so
okay interesting so we're uh so what's
the big takeaway for you what was it
that was so magical for you there
that I mean you're thinking about it
you're talking about you want to go back
and make the documentary I mean what's
going on there
uh well I think I went in
really in a bad place and it felt like
it gave me so much I I learned so much
and I was kind of in awe at the way
plants were able to to help me and
communicate with me like to to drink
something that's not even psychoactive
and then have experiences that I would
not normally have in my Waking Life that
were kind of giving me like Revelations
or or realizations was like it just felt
kind of sorry about this noise outside
someone's leaking okay you're good okay
um it just felt like other otherworldly
you know and I like I feel like I left
with more self-love than I've ever had
more more peace
and also not only in the way it helped
me find more peace like I watched it
really help other people you guys talked
about this briefly
um I know it sounds crazy I mentioned
someone with crohn's disease and holes
in their stomach oh didn't you say it
cured Crohn's disease yeah in the video
I corrected myself I don't think you
guys saw it it said like it stopped the
symptoms so I had a friend who went to
the center like I want to say like 14
months ago and he
um just hasn't had Crohn's disease
symptoms since
um and then the hernia was like a
completely separate situation well you
said it got rid of the holes in
someone's body were you talking about
Crohn's
what was that about I don't know much
about it but so this girl came in this
woman and she had she she said she had a
hole in her stomach from from lifting
she a hernia I don't I really don't
about it
um and she went to a doctor they said
that she had to have this invasive
surgery she didn't want to so she came
to the center and was like I heard you
guys can do things can you do it
um she went through this experience
where she had like a sap on her patch on
her stomach she was drinking various
plants
um a week later she sent a picture of an
updated CT scan at her doctor after she
left um and the hole was just gone
the hole was gone the hole was gone I
also have the receipts if you
want I want receipts yeah I'm gonna need
to back that up okay
I need the whole pot pre and post hole
pics
pre-post hole on the way I figured you'd
asked did a cure any illness of yours uh
did you feel that you I would say I went
in with more uh like mental um issues
and I would say uh yeah I mean I I think
I the biggest takeaway I Learned was
um I'm able to sort of remove myself
more from the melodrama of my life and
and and feel a little bit more peace
like regardless of what's Happening
which is wonderful considering what's
happening right now it's been really
weird to be at the center of this
conversation
um
also I think you and I may I'm sending
you on on Zoom is that a good place to
yeah right then you can pull that up
yeah let's see them holes I don't want
to assume but I think you and I have a
similar condition
um I have it's called tourettic OCD
okay yeah that sounds similar I don't
know I've never heard of that but it's
probably it sounds like the same thing
because Tourette's is a type of OCD I
think it's like part of the same family
you know I noticed for me it gets it
worse when I'm in like a high pressure
situation or I feel anxiety but I've
noticed that like the more General work
I'm doing whether it's like meditation
or not but also going to the center it's
helped that condition a lot have you
heard of Nexium
that's my next uh Adventure there's like
Skye Mark uh uh Elliot he's doing really
amazing stuff for people into rats I
heard about this yeah
well because you guys you guys made a
joke about it peeling Tourette's and I
was like the fact that it actually
helped my
well you're right I think Tourette's is
highly affected by stress stressors and
stuff so I think it affects it in
general well-being it helps yeah
so I sent the picture so how long has it
been since you left do you feel that the
effects are lasting on you do you feel
like permanently Changed by it
I think it's been three months
um I feel I feel permanently changed but
here's the thing there's
you can go and you can do Ayahuasca you
can do this whole process and not really
change very much they say 80 of the work
is in the integration so it means that
you have to come home you have to
actually take the things that you
learned and then apply it to your
everyday life
um and so that's that's what I'm in the
process of doing it's like I feel
changed but it's because every single
day I wake up and I choose to do the
things that I know are going to help me
like meditate it sounds like when you
can't you describe coming back and then
feel you felt like so centered and whole
but then at the same time felt
completely alienated that doesn't sound
that good
I think what it is and uh this is like a
common sentiment in when you're going
through spiritual Awakenings of sorts is
like you start uh noticing parts of your
life that you don't identify with
anymore uh whether it's habits or where
you live or people in your life and so I
just I just started feeling disconnected
from the things in my life that I needed
to disconnect from I think there was a
misinterpretation on the podcast about
what I was saying in the in the video
like for the for the very most part I'm
connected to everyone in my life I had
never been disconnected from my family
um it was like two friends that I that I
lost along the way why why how did you
lose them
um
one of my one of my friends
um she was really upset about the fact
that I wasn't speaking up online and she
basically said that she would if I
didn't and I was like can you please let
me handle this on my own
um and I I don't know it was it became a
bit hostile and we just sort of fell out
but she didn't end up saying anything
I don't think so
oh that's interesting and was this a
good friend of yours well that seems
like a shame to lose a friend over that
yes and
um I
I think it was sort of a friendship that
I knew even before I left was was one
that wasn't like the long run
okay you weren't feeling it
can I maybe hit you with something of a
paradox I'm noticing okay
you you went to this Retreat and you
became centered and you became like uh
super aware
yet but at the same time it seems like
you've made at least it seems from the
outside uh a somewhat big mistake in the
way that you handled the situation it
seems to be at odds a little bit like if
if you were centered and if it had like
bringed you up to like heightened
Enlightenment I feel like that may have
been uh
something of a clear decision for you to
make
I mean just I think just because I was
feeling centered doesn't mean I'm not a
human who makes mistakes for me being
centered was a lot about
um addressing my workaholism which I
talked about in my video and so I for me
actually like not speaking not feeling
pressure to speak up too soon when I
felt sort of like debilitated was I
think for me personally even though
maybe it wasn't good for my career for
other people
was the best choice right um in terms of
how I navigated making the video I just
I mean
I don't know however centered you can be
I think it was just you never know how
things are going to pan out
and then I was just curious what what
was the second friend that that you lost
as a consequence of the retreat
simply
highly associated with the first one oh
okay okay you know a Duo I see here's
the I got the pictures of the uh the
mirror the miracle hole Yeah so here is
here's this one
and then let me pull up the other one I
think that's the after so this is pre
this is the whole
yeah that's the hole okay
that's a big hole look at take a look at
that yeah I see it that's a hole it's a
big hole
so and then here is uh
uh whole list I don't see a hole here
I mean
I mean I'm not a doctor
but I don't see a hole
there's nothing circled on that one I
don't notice that whatever that's worth
that's 2D huh
yeah
let me look at the beginning before and
after gaming evidence so
that's a [__] this is the stomach oh
yeah that's a hole
and a hole in it
but then here
I don't this is no hole I mean that
appears to be uh dark spots
right
and this happened in one week
no she was there I think for like three
and a half weeks and then the week after
she going home she went to the doctor
again and she sent him just a message
like in awe obviously because it's kind
of crazy I don't want to be rude but do
you really believe that this
yeah I mean I really got to know I got
to know her I don't there's I don't see
any incentive for lying and my friend as
well with the Crohn's disease like you
know I talked to him and he's like yeah
I'm I'm blown away I don't understand
but for 14 months I just haven't had
symptoms you know well that one's more
believable just because I know Crohn's
disease has periods of like good and bad
phases but a whole this man lost the
hole the whole filled in
laughs
here it is yeah did this person um take
the ayahuasca
she drank Ayahuasca but I it wasn't the
Ayahuasca that helped her with that it
was the other plants that's like a
master plant yet is working with all
these various different plants in the in
the rainforest and so she she for the
whole time she was there she had this
like thing on her stomach
and she was drinking different plants
okay listen this is just out of pocket I
mean who made this
this is Mr BEAST's new video Maestro I
went to Peru and I healed a thousand
holes
maybe a future collab for your
documentary
oh that was quick yeah that's Cameron
for he's the best it was somebody on the
Reddit oh somebody already posted that
on the subject
so if you if you believe that this
Ayahuasca can cure
uh
uh mental I don't want to call it
necessary mental illness I don't know
what's the word for like uh but it can
cure let's just say mental illness for
lack of better word can cure physical
ill ailments then this is uh an urgent
and Paramount uh medical Discovery isn't
it
to clarify it's not it's not necessarily
Ayahuasca that's doing this it's the
other plan or whatever they're doing
over there yeah not necessarily yeah
that's why I'm like I'm like I gotta go
film something there it's it's kind of
uh mind-shattering and I know I know
from the outside it sounds crazy but I I
met so many people who came and went and
and helped them
where did you originally get the idea to
do the Ayahuasca retreat
I think I mean I I probably saw it on
Chelsea Handler like years ago and I I
was intrigued and so I I went to one
Center and it it was really it helped me
a lot so I was like how can I explore
this further you went to a center in
America or in Peru no I went to one in
Peru like just for a week different
Center and it was great but I wanted to
do something a little bit more intensive
let me ask you this you met another
thing you mentioned in your video was
that the Maestro has kids and there's
kids running around that I found that a
little bizarre
that's actually part of the reason I
chose this Center because the first one
I went to it was it was very westernized
um and I wanted to have a very authentic
experience the job that she's doing I
mean she's staying in ceremonies until
really late at night she kind of has to
live where she works um and so and she
has kids she has like five kids so she
they all they live there with her they
kind of have like their family lives in
this house and then a little bit to the
side you have this the business like
this do you think the kids take
Ayahuasca I read something I was reading
about another Maestro who said he
started taking Ayahuasca at 12. I was
like what the [__]
I know that um
I don't I know that she's she has a kid
who who drank for the first time when I
was there and she made him wait until he
I think he's 19.
um that's a responsible age yeah that's
good I hope you can't hear this noise
now it's pretty it's fine no you're good
okay great
um but she does have someone working
with her at the center who did start
drinking when they were 12 and is now 90
years old so I do I do know that there
are people
in that culture who do drink really
young
90 he started at 12 he's 90. is he his
house is mined is he still there
hard does he only speaks shapibo so I
have no knowing
I have no way of knowing
right I see damn 90 okay let me [__] I
mean he works every ceremony and he he
he shows up which is pretty impressive
for a 90 year old can I ask you a
question you don't I'm not asking about
your you personally but we're people
having uh sexual interactions there at
all
you're not allowed to okay that's
interesting yeah that's good that's
that's a nice strike against the cult uh
uh accusation because I know them cult
leaders boy
they got one thing on their mind okay so
no sexual interaction is prohibited yeah
and what happens if people get caught
doing the hanky-panky
I I don't know what happens maybe you'll
slap on the wrist I mean you're kind of
just people want to follow the rules
there
you're there to make it work and it's
part of the process is to not do that so
I think most people don't okay that's
interesting
I think it's you want to get as uh like
maybe like ethereal or like uh up up
here as possible so that's why you're
not engaging in sexual behavior or
you're not eating foods that are really
stimulating like the less the body needs
to process the more that you you're like
emotional and so that makes sense to me
when I do stuff like that I don't I
don't feel sexual at all but I I can see
why they would I like that they prohibit
it I think that's good
um
what if the leader says he needs a piece
I'm not going to say that
um
um it seems to me that uh
yeah I don't think it sounds very culty
now that I've talked to you
you know me neither but it does sound a
little it does sound a little bizarre I
mean you know that I know that yeah but
I I know a lot of people that took
Ayahuasca and had positive experiences
so I know that's a thing but the whole
healing thing strikes me as a little bit
weird like you you want to do the
documentary and what is the purpose of
the documentary to highlight the
the healing properties of the plants or
what
I I think it's a com It's a combination
of things and I'm still sort of figuring
out the angle
um I I'm really intrigued by how much
plants can help people and I think this
Center is is like a way in to explore
like tell the story through
human characters
um but yeah to teach about plant
medicines and and just like let people
know that this exists I know it sounds
really crazy but I think we're coming at
it from like a very Western perspective
um and we've lost a lot of touch with
with what it means to be like creatures
who are connected to the Earth like
there's just a lot of wisdom that we
don't engage with anymore
I don't find the sound uh
uh I don't mean to sound uh obtuse but
isn't most medicine derived from plants
I'm probably yeah I I think there's
something about like using it in in its
raw form in this form that's really
powerful okay yeah so it's the amount of
processing because like for example when
you take a pill it's highly processed
there's no plan left but you do process
Ayahuasca I saw a video of how they made
it
um what do you mean by process they get
the roots and the twigs and the leaves
and the bark and they boil it right into
like a brew it's basically like two
plants that that they make into a tea
like a thick
awful tasting tea
um who was this the person who got their
stomach healed was this someone that you
spent a lot of time with there
yeah um it's a girl her name's Veronica
I think she'd be fine with me saying
that
um
I don't know how old she is maybe like
29 she has two kids she was really
worried that she wouldn't be able to
pick them up how long she was there for
five weeks
um she was there for three and a half
weeks and she has a partner who was who
was with her kids okay okay
and um so shh i i i the thing that
worries me about like the stomach
healing stuff is that
based on what I've seen this stuff
doesn't really pan out and I hope that
you know people who are desperately sick
that need medical intervention or or
let's say Western Medical intervention
or people who are just maybe
maybe people who are looking for a cure
to something that's terminal or some
something like that you know that
they'll be seeking uh falsely out a cure
for something that that can't really
help them at all and maybe he's taking
away some of their precious time that
they could have been with their family
or something
I know that in my experience there
everyone that I met
got what they came for and at the same
time obviously they don't they don't
claim that they're going to fix or be
able to heal anything in fact I think
they for they do a lot of preliminary
calls before people come and they will
tell you if they don't think they can
help you
who do you talk to when they call you
uh well they have people who run like
the business side of things and they'll
they'll connect you with the Maestra uh
for like a preliminary conversation
I I didn't have that conversation with
them but I think it depends on what you
what could you you have to do it like an
intake form and I think if they feel
like they need to follow up with you
based on what you're looking for then
they'll have a conversation with you can
I ask you the cost of the retreat
yeah it was uh less than 2500.
yeah well I I extended a week when I was
there it was about that much it's not
that bad right not at all that's pretty
it's actually really on the inexpensive
side maybe a good idea for a company
Retreat yeah where else are you going to
go somewhere for five weeks for two or
three grand and they feed you they have
so that's all inclusive plants stomach
or the
puke sucking included
full event all inclusive
pool access
full access nope oh
oh that's a bummer cold showers
cold showers okay Olivia you seem really
sold I can I can feel enthusiasm oh my
gosh thank you so much
no I would follow up with that stomach
person
you know what I mean
what is a hole in the stomach by the way
is that I don't even think that's a real
medical condition you can't have a
hernia she said it oh a hernia a hernia
well hernias can be cured fixed they can
she said that she it's just that they
didn't want to get the surgery right
it's a very it's like kind of an intense
surgery to fix a hernia and um
so let me look at those photos again
I mean I think it's kind of along the
lines of like you know I have a friend
right now who has lupus and she's using
a raw diet to help I think it's just
using but a hernia
I know it's a little bit more it's the
hernia is like a you're physically
moving a part of your body whereas yeah
lupus I don't know much about lupus but
it's an autoimmune some yeah I could see
drinking some like mentee or something
for that do we like mint is mint healing
heals my breath I like it so once again
whole hernia
mm-hmm
how do we know that uh to be on how why
is this Con I'm just gonna be straight
why is this compelling to you I mean
it's just two random images
I feel that I feel that she doesn't have
uh she doesn't have um an affiliation
stock yeah she doesn't have own stock in
the Ayahuasca retreat no certainly not I
mean she was fair enough she was there
on the journey with me like I saw her
being like I really hope this works like
I'm so stressed about you know and then
it didn't and it did
I guess stranger things have happened I
don't know stranger things have happened
can it cure cancer
I don't I don't know that right I don't
know about that right let's just head
your bet and say no that's probably the
same answer let's stay on the same
probably the safe answer all right well
listen
definitely not a cold I'll give that
stamp right there not a quote
thank you
but yeah I I totally see where the
I see where the confusion happened so we
got that's we got that cleared up no
association
with the original uh cult people that
try to recruit you
uh but yeah it sounds like you had a
nice Ayahuasca journey and uh your fans
kind of just were worried about you and
and uh that's what happened you know
what I mean
didn't handle it in the best way
yeah we all like you said we all make
mistakes I I understand uh the the mind
frame of having gone through something
and not feeling ready to like deal with
with something you know what I mean like
I totally get that what is this question
did you meet any machine elves
oh I feel like I know what this question
means I don't know what that means
um a lot of people who do Ayahuasca will
tell you that they experience
um what seemed to be like alien robots
working on their body
okay did anyone there experience that uh
no one I know their experience that I
don't think but I remember at the very
first Ayahuasca Retreat I went to
someone was telling said exactly that um
that's normal whoa I want that that
ain't normal
it's normal for those kinds but you know
what I listen I'm very Pro uh I
encourage people to experiment with
drugs responsibly so I got not you know
I mean like I encourage it all and uh
but it sounds like you you you sound
like you had a good experience over
there and you feel like a better person
for it
nice are you going to start making
videos again are you getting back into
the swing of it what's your plans in the
future
I gotta say this whole uh internet
debacle has kind of like knocked the
wind out of me so I think I just like
need a moment
um but yeah I mean I I want to make
videos I'm just sort of like figuring
out what what that looks like and what
feels good to make I'm trying to
approach it differently now kind of like
what led me to going was the the
workaholism like the hamster wheel of
being on YouTube sure um and so now I'm
trying to figure out how to how to
engage with it differently sure yeah I
get that yeah [__] cast too by the way
if you're there watching evidently yeah
they actually had a show where where
someone on that I think was called No
Chasers they called them out for not
paying them it's like oh how are they
not paying people
spread of of stories fast what the [__]
yeah earlier I saw those comments about
Hassan and when we mentioned on air I
saw a lot of follow-up comments of
people saying that uh Hassan still
[__] about it to this day so I guess
he he had a pretty negative experience
I'm gonna ask him how much cash does him
yeah I don't understand how the people
keep working with them after that you
know I've heard about all these podcasts
production companies they sound also
show so shitty
but I guess that was your experience eh
do you have Ayahuasca with you did you
bring any home
you don't have any I guess you is it
easy to try you probably couldn't travel
because it's like a drink right I guess
you could put in a thermos
I mean maybe you could bring the raw
plants and and make your own Brew
is it not illegal in the state I feel
like Customs no it's definitely you have
to be in order to have or like
orchestrate Ayahuasca it needs to be
considered a
religious institution or something like
that oh that's true I think there are
Ayahuasca clinics here and they just
they're like oh yeah we're religious
is it religious though or do you find
that or it's more like a spiritual thing
I would say it's spiritual I think
that's just like the guys that people
have to use here in order to make it
happen well and also by the way I don't
think until the end of the episode did
you guys realize I was in Peru if I was
doing all of that stuff in Los Angeles
like yeah that'd be very cool thing yeah
yeah just a different culture so sure
you know different different contexts
yes yeah
well
very good thank you for calling and
sharing your story with us you know
thank you I appreciate that a lot yeah
and I hope that you can uh
you know find the PATH forward for
yourself in terms of of uh
this this job that we've decided for
ourselves it is crazy I mean it is
psychotic the work we do at the end of
the day it's really [__] weird
yourself from it it's yeah it's
well I'm heavily medicated just on
different stuff
I'm on all kinds of anti press I'm on
Lexapro Wellbutrin
and uh you you call it Ayahuasca I call
it lexical Lexus
by the way somebody sent this on the
Reddit this is like an ad you see an
antidepressant commercial my my dumb ass
being left out the video game
there you go I'm the poster boy for
antidepressant there you go
all right Alex
anything else
see you soon girl
I was gonna wear this in the show but I
didn't want to I didn't want it to seem
like I was trying to win you guys over
but I'm gonna put it on now that we're
we're ending it okay we got okay yes
I love that [__] too that's a really
cool one oh thank you that's so nice
thank you yeah but I I'm with you girl I
get it you know what I mean I get it
thank you for that and really thank you
for having me on it was it was a good
opportunity to just express everything
awesome all right well be good if you go
back let Olivia know I think yeah I will
we'll be travel partners are you
planning to go back anytime soon
I do want to I I am okay full truth it's
comedically painful
um I'm leaving tomorrow to go get
footage in Peru for this docuser so how
long have you been back
uh
three three months maybe three and a
half oh you've been back for a minute
yeah and you just didn't talk about it
until after a while yeah I just I kept
trying to like I made multiple videos
but it was just not coming together
so you're gonna go back with just you
are you bringing a camera crew what's
the just you no it's just me I'm just
trying to get some like preliminary
interviews to put together like a
concept video for a pitch deck nothing
you gonna be taking Ayahuasca what
during your visit there
I don't think so but if the op
presents itself
well why wouldn't the opportunity
present itself it's an Ayahuasca Retreat
because I'm not I'm not going and like
paying for the retreat I just I'm just
going in footage okay yeah they'll hook
you up
hahaha I hope so
there it is all right
we'll have fun how long you gonna be
there so the fans know that you didn't
get recruited into a call again
well it's only I'm gonna be there like
10 days but I think I'm gonna stay in
South America for a little while because
I'm really trying to learn Spanish so it
may be like a month okay there you go a
month guys and you promise if you're
gone for longer than a month we'll get
an update
okay
okay there it is just a simple update
you know maybe on Instagram if not
YouTube Just say guys I'm a cool
you know a month Jordan Peterson wants
more updates but I'm letting you off the
hook with the month
thank you all right Alex be good uh you
know have have a good time be safe we
believe in you
thank you all right all right take care
nice chatting thank you bye thanks for
having me bye
there it is
not a cult
I'm seeing impulsive is on the cast
website too dude how do people sign up
like the thought of putting my baby my
child
in the hands of some other [__] like
you there's no need to include them you
it's baby you have always been a very uh
DIY kind of guy you always try and do
things yourself and a lot of people
aren't uh
you know it's easier it's easier to just
have a turnkey solution it's just like
you you handle all the stuff I just show
up and and talk it is easier yeah but
the amount that you
um relinquish to them is so not worth it
you know I'm fully with you I I like and
respect that you have always been a you
know do everything internally kind of
dude thank you Dan thank you I
appreciate that let's bring the chat
back open okay one second but um
okay that was interesting yeah I I see
where the big uh disconnect came from
there turns out everything you read on
the Internet isn't always true shocking
but I do feel that we can definitively
say here and now at this very moment
not a quote
not a cult yeah I think that's fair the
healing thing is a little
I think I need some more receipts I mean
you and I the healing people know we're
we're not really on board with the
alternative medicine stuff anybody I
mean that's talk about uh chiropractors
on the show but uh that's like you know
at the
the evangelicals theme and stand up and
walk demon yeah none of you guys will
have chiropractors there's a handicapped
demon in you ceremonies frankly frankly
I would say this is less [__] than
chiropractors for sure oh yeah we
chiropractors I think you're gonna say
Evangelical oh no dealing oh well that
too this is like I'm fully out on
Chiropractic that's what I'm saying at
least with this there's like the
ambiguity of like yeah most medicine is
derived from one plant or another so
like this though I'm skeptical I can at
least follow the logic there whereas you
know the chiropractors I'm gonna I'm
gonna snap your neck and it's gonna cure
your Crohn's disease
that's that's not anything and I hate to
say it too but acupuncture I'm sorry
yeah I know everybody got mad at me and
acupuncture the other day when I said
that very sorry I know I'm sorry it's
just it is I don't know I was just
explain it to you all I know is that
it's worked for me once okay good do it
done good good if it works for you
enjoy thanks guys thank you guys it
works it works
um
but I agree yeah it's less [__] than
that
we should I see people still conflicted
some people are saying is a cult listen
if there's not a dude there whose
[__] kids is not a cult as far as I'm
concerned that's
that's the bottom line
what's your I think the physical healing
is so cringy it's and very dangerous
because that price on like really weak
weak people who has
like tried everything and then they go
there to spend their money and to like
think it's going to repair a hole in
their stomach I think that's kind of I
I'm 100 with you I mean listen it's her
experience so I'm not I'm not here to
call her a liar or anything but um
so once it somehow acupuncture is
covered by Insurance my insurance mine
too ELO once had some kind of chronic
back pain and they sent to her
acupuncturist and it was like in this
[__] nasty like strip mall some weird
ass white dude
she was very uncomfortable yeah
you know what I mean
you should have gone to my acupuncturist
you see like what what does your
acupuncturist look like my godmother
just did it for me once she does
acupuncture though oh that's her
profession yeah that's her thing I don't
know I don't know how much I believe in
acupuncture but like love her love her
love her you're the best let's do a pull
cult not cold it is not a cult though
guys well I don't know why I'm even
giving you the power of the vote on this
one not a cult
but that's the other thing where it's
like do you go plan
you hear a lot of the same tropes with
this stuff like plants are saving us all
and it's like well
pretty much all medicine is derived from
Plants right
man I mean isn't everything kind of
derived from natural Origins like we
live on we live on the planet it's all
natural baby that is so true like what's
not natural tell me what's not natural
Cheetos
Cheetos are not natural you're right
Jimmy Lee's hairline
that ain't from this Earth you're right
okay well done you guys you guys got me
thank you but you know what
I think she's super nice and and I
totally understand uh
unfortunately what kind of what she went
through in terms of not communicating
like I I know what she means so
just kind of an unfortunate situation
uh
interestingly that she lost a couple of
relationships through the yeah that's
sad they were gonna out her that was a
little weird yeah that's not that's not
their place yeah yeah I'm with her on
that
okay not a cult just odd someone said
and I agree with that
some people thought she was being
dishonest about the lock I don't know
who puts a lock on the outside of the
door though let's be real it's weird
there was a giant window in it that she
could have escaped that was my
perception because I saw people were
like freaking out about the lock and
then like in that same shot you could
see that like it didn't look if that's a
prison it's not very secure no it was
like a barn door that's fair yeah that's
fair it wasn't a very strong walk either
you could definitely shoulder it off
yeah
there it is there it is
uh
uh also to me when I see this and again
I'm just
I'm coming from a very skeptical mind
you know but I think these dudes are
just making a ton of [__] money
[__] yeah I mean like they she gets
pre-called by like some [__] business
person it's just like a random white
person
well we don't know that uh
I'm making assumptions here right
you know
I mean I kind of had that Vibe too but I
don't know like I said 2500 bucks that
is nine weeks I mean if it's a scam they
could be scamming for a lot more
My worry is uh if if you you come to
them and you called them and you say yo
I'm really [__] sick they increased
the price the more desperate you are
that's kind of my word
you know what if you're first that's
that's for sure true but like because
well he goes I have a she said her
friend called and goes I have a hernia
can you cure it they're like yeah bro
I'll just put some bamboo on it you're
good whatever right
you know I I think it's [__] up I I
can't lie I'm taking this I I think it's
messed up to to promise that kind of
stuff and to promote it
well again I I agree with you that was
her experience so I can't I can't tell
her like that you know her perception is
wrong no she's not not she is not at
fault necessarily no I agree with that
yeah
[Laughter]
without me
uh what about this one Kim Kardashian
give Kardashian
Kardashian in Kardashian Kim Kardashian
oh wait Sam you said there was a new one
it was I looked it was actually old but
I would still want to see it it came up
okay I'll try to find it Kim Kardashian
I saw people just leaving the comment
Kim Kardashian 1000.
well do you love that Kim Kardashian Kim
Kardashian
yeah okay I mean listen
love that she's you know when she
reached out and said she wanted to call
in I was pretty sure I was like oh this
isn't a cult then
right because they wouldn't let you uh
speak to anything they'd be very
controlling of the communication yeah
exactly
so let's see we got all kinds of Goofs
and gaffs uh to look over we've got uh
oh Charlie retracted I didn't did
Charlie retract his
idubbbz analysis uh from what I
understand and not necessarily a full
retraction but an acknowledgment that uh
many people did not like rewind time he
had to say about it here's somewhere in
Peru right now
apparently uh some plants
uh you guys are funny love that
um yeah just Charlie's video seems like
and he acknowledges this that he
underestimated Ian's influence like that
was a big part of it there was a few
other points that he hadn't clarified
but yeah that was a big okay a fair but
like underestimating his influence I
mean come on his videos were huge
yeah all right I got a lot of people
don't like Ethan and that's totally fine
you don't even like everyone or anything
no I get it you know
all right I'm gonna go pee I'm gonna
come right back and then we'll have a
bunch of other fun stuff to go over be
right back sounds good
hey chat welcome back sorry some of you
we're doing the thing that chat does and
uh being extremely rude to our guests
um so we had to shut it off uh but we're
glad to have you back to play I'm
looking at some super chats right now
Claire the ten dollar to play Devil's
Advocate a lot of conditions are made
worse by diet and stress if you have an
experience that decreases your stress
and causes you to eat clean that makes
sense yeah there's a logic to that right
I mean
it can be
feeling to take some time off especially
over a month to just go chill in the
jungle does sound pretty nice
yeah I know about like silent Retreats
and stuff like that it seems great just
kind of clear your mind for like a week
seems [__] Epic
silence sounds hard yeah that would be
tough for you yeah that'd be really
that'd be really hard sounds just about
right for me
we will be at different Retreats wacky
[__] says it's my 21st birthday I love
you guys oh no oh not really my birthday
okay at least they acknowledge that it
was [__] thank you uh happy
non-birthday to you then 21. [__] you
he's not they're not they're not Antonio
they're not
what but 21 was mentioned in the Super
Chat
uh they were joking they were I gotta
played a son's contract fair enough fair
enough uh Valentina London said the crew
should spend the bbtv money on an
Ayahuasca Retreat I wouldn't say no
I also wouldn't say no
[Music]
I don't think it's going to cure my
hernia but I would I would I wouldn't
say no to trying out Alaska
um although I was kind of saying this
before the show
and maybe this is naive maybe it is
significantly different but from
everything I've read about Ayahuasca
it's very similar to DMT which you can
do without going
to
Peru for a month and also it doesn't
make you [__] your brains out so
um
but I know I walk the last like way
longer DMT is like a little 20 minute
you know trip so maybe maybe it's
different uh Juliana said uh rather get
rid of Ryan cav-cav or Andrew Tate
neither
oh is this a question
for content
ten dollars rather get rid of Ryan Kafka
or Andrew Tate I guess this is a
question
um I mean Andrew Tate obviously is a way
worse like influence like who the [__]
knows Brian Kavanaugh outside of our
audience and he makes us giggle yeah
right yeah yeah we've gotten a lot of
joy for making fun of that guy and he's
gonna take a big L in the end too yes
indeed
um Jas actually turned 26. thank you
happy birthday thank you for being
honest about your age
thank you
six months of gifted membership wait
you've gotten it six months in a row
how does that happen
that seems incredibly lucky right
definitely because it just picks it at
random I haven't even gotten in on my
work account are you sure you're not
paying and you forgot is it one of the
situations where you stopped and you're
getting charged every month without
realizing it
uh always using my members Milestone
chat to say I love you Dan well I love
you too thank you
uh you can't write a message if you get
a gifted or was that just a comment
uh
no it was the yeah it was the Milestone
thing can you do a milestone if you get
a gifted though
frankly I don't know I think she's
paying for it I think you might want to
check your uh credit card statement hold
on guys a new uh a new Sam uh sound bite
just I haven't practiced this one enough
okay well let's hear let's hear I
[__] childhood is screaming right now
bro
holy [__] this is the new Glam Light
Scooby-Doo Collection is it coming
okay I'll know when it happens
look at this makeup bag
that's awesome wait hold on we gotta
grab that Zach
the life may go back
I like Kim Kardashian better though you
can't beat that you've got that [__] Kim
Kardashian that is so funny
yeah she's great though if you have any
other ones let us know I will I do I
yeah no no hate to her
family's walking around yesterday saying
one over and over just around the house
oh I was saying she had another one that
was like this is my experience with it
Swift heiress tour
[Music]
oh man that's so good
um here's uh some some fun Goofs at the
top here
I thought this was interesting someone
pulled this from a really old episode
one of the must have been one of the
first
uh like a sound for like man oh you're
so true Dan I want to get a soundboard
where we get like slamming bradberries
and necks so like you can you can be
like the audio engineer are you up for
that
cool hell yeah I want to get weird and
wild with this show we can step this up
to weirder parts
come a long way since then
that's from the 15th episode 15th okay
yep so that's funny I mean it took like
I would say I think we got our sound
situation
uh really
going like I don't know how wouldn't you
say Zach like it feels like maybe a year
and a half or something I joined episode
69. that was like my first day on the
job but it took a while before it was in
a really good place I'd say so yeah I'd
say about a month or two and then it
just progressively started building
yeah but um
um yeah
you guys don't have to hear me click the
she I thought the bench was wide
I used to ride that button I used to
ride that button so hard
I still I still think it's funny I
you could eat that could be the girl
that Tick Tock girl Sam
you want to try that true you want to
try that let me practice it
hit it hit it with uh uh you practice at
home and bring it in yeah I'll practice
why
it's powerful you want to give it a shot
hold on play it one more time I thought
I can't
like yell like that I can't you need
cigarettes yeah yeah
that of course is Roseanne uh after her
cancellation for calling a black woman a
gorilla or something
if you thought the [__] was white why
also kind of interestingly this was the
Cutie Cinderella episode everybody knows
that faded horrible situation but one
thing that did foreshadow what does that
look like to you on my shirt
this is crazy
cheers
[Music]
boom if only I had it then huh
although that was the um Catalyst I
would say to finally the final Catalyst
yeah that was that was it
there it is
um dude
dude
somebody submitted this just for me and
boy were they right I saw this on our
subreddit oh wait no did I
something else
so funny I don't know what it is about
people who are injured and then the
person's supposed to help them hurts
them more It's the funniest [__]
thing ever
check this out dude
oh my god oh [__]
like assuming that guy had like really
bad back damage right they got them all
queued up
and then why what was he even trying to
do
and you can see it's kind of slow moving
the guy knows he's about to just he's a
big boy too yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's like the biggest
oh
[__] dude just imagine this guy broke
his back or something God
and it's funny I saw this myself and I
went to go send it to you and you had
just sent it like five minutes earlier I
was like of course
I think if you will look closely at the
guy's face it almost looks like he's
smiling
the the guy
I mean let's look closely at his face
here if we can like
oh you know it's crazy he's just on the
hard concrete floor
hey yeah
yeah if he I think he lifts his neck
perfectly there if he had a broken neck
he'd die like he'd probably die
yeah he did lift his neck although there
was I mean people are gathered around
look like a pretty serious injury yeah
she's smiling or is he like cringing I
think this might be cringe but then he
can't get off him real fast too because
he's pretty big
he kind of has to roll off him and I
don't think he has any control of his
body in this moment
he really took his time getting off him
you know oh [__] yeah do you think
they're like helicopter people or why
they have those helmets that's a good
question why are they all dolled up wait
he makes some boots a noise when he
drops is it the guy let's turn it up
yeah let's hear it listen
oh
it's the guy he's Lance
elf is here
don't worry
I'm gonna pull that he slammed the air
right out of him dude
turn that up
that's old
we got to get details I want to know
what
oh you gotta know what the [__] man
did he die a wrestling game totally
someone said if he wasn't dead he is now
yeah that's a good one love that people
are saying the lady said uh they killed
him she said that
yo
[Laughter]
why would you even assume that posture
why what's he attempting to do walk
around him man
oh
oh [__] the way he kicks both of his
feet up too is just so fun yeah I was
just gonna say did he slap him in the
face or did they just go right above his
face let me watch I think he tried to
no he went over his face yeah
he sits like directly on his boss
oh yeah oh yeah
that's fantastic
rest in peace to the dearly Departed
[__] that is great
there it is
if you were gonna enjoy that one
okay
I've been to the EDC once that's the the
Electric Daisy Carnival where they play
uh EDM music yeah EDM at EDC I've been
to three you want to say now if this is
your thing
I'm cool with all that I just thought
when I went there The Vibes were
horrible
it felt hostile and weird I didn't feel
safe there
but
these Vibes are even worse check out the
prices on this food at EDC this actually
I've never seen anything like this this
is actually upsetting I think it's
fairly uh well this is this I mean
Festival food is always insanely
overpriced this this is one of the worst
I've ever seen okay so yeah look at this
tacos
seventy dollars what
yeah
and then watch this
Pizza 96 dollars
a hundred dollars for a [__] Pizza
yep
okay
Sushi a hundred dollars for six rolls
hundred flat
what the [__] I mean that's it that's
[__] up that's disgusting there needs
to be I feel like that should be
regulated that that I mean that's
[__] insane it's just so gross
hundred dollars
fruits and veggies fruit platter 85
veggie platter 85 that's fruits and
vegetables
I'll take I'll take one veggie and fruit
platter please that'd be a hundred and
seventy dollars
it's an orange it's half of an orange
and two strawberries you know it's bad
one oh yeah like rotting
hey are you hungry
I'm feeling like some fresh fruit right
now I heard they got a fruit platter
all right I'll go pick it up
hey do you have 500 cash on you
oh someone also said the a bottle of
water twenty dollars
yeah I mean that sense
sounds about right
sounds about right I that I mean I guess
I don't go out a lot to this kind of
stuff but this this is
that's disgusting I mean I'm boycotting
them me too
I haven't been to a raven a decade at
this point but yeah me too you know the
top comment is they need to make laws
for this food water bathroom should all
be accessible things I man
you need to take a [__] 20 bucks the
thing is like I I doubt there's making
more money
than if it was reasonably priced like
who is buying that
who yeah I mean I don't know
I don't know I guess I mean the thing is
is like you're there at the party and
it's
midnight like are you gonna leave and go
get some fast food real quick captive
audience yeah exactly it's like what you
don't have other options really so
because that [__] doesn't start till
like super late right the EDC uh EDC
actually start is like all day
at least it used to be I don't know when
it used to be in L.A guys hit me with
the house music
guys I'm gonna get some french fries
y'all want some
yeah get me French fries too and a
bottle of water
all right sick bro do you have a
thousand on you
yo I just took out a second mortgage on
my house so I could get us all water
yo I just got an advance on my check
yo I just took I just took a like 30
interest rate
on my credit card to get us some water
[Music]
[__] that
I'm skinny boy people are saying it I'm
feeling skinny yeah
210. Ethan is a skinny Legend thanks for
saying that thanks Jordan it's crazy
that it's actually happening you know
what I mean happening somebody said EDC
has free water
oh that's good wow it's free water
yeah there's some Chatters free water I
remember being three back in the day but
also I think the last EDC in La was the
last EDC in LA because like a 16 year
old girl died and uh hit the music
hit it they banned big hey can we get a
water for her she's I think she's having
a heat stroke
twenty dollars
now I really think she's sick she might
be dying sure sounds good twenty dollars
[Music]
you want a Coke Coke's only 10 bucks
all right let's give her a Coke
it's not helping I only have 10 bucks
give her a Diet Coke
[Music]
ah yes EDC
yeah it's happening man it's crazy
I'm still massive though I'll show you
guys
[Music]
going on here
well you know it's progress though
it's like a lot
[Music]
wow
there's a lot left to go man
did you just say pretty I said for free
oh
for free ready I love I love our fans
give it up for free for them
oh here's another crash you know
make your Monday a little better watch
people get hurt
makes it easier to get through the day
yeah
whoa oh this is not gonna be good oh
it's great oh oh my Lord did anybody get
out of that that guy at the end King
he's like first place bye this guy's
like I'm still in the race I don't know
what y'all doing yo I mean that is so
sketchy though they're so close
yeah they're [__] idiots what can I
say all right dumb asses
I don't even know what happened they all
just started spilling man it looks like
a muddy ass wet road yeah and that's why
I'm never gonna go bicycling again
that's why share the road
green light red light
um yeah that would explain it
uh this guy was super interesting I saw
this on Instagram oh wait no this is a
different guy
yo a different guy did this did we I saw
another one of a dude who did this to
gain like three inches or five inches do
we ever watch that one you're talking
about the limb lengthening thing yeah we
did a whole segment on it like a year
ago no I know but I saw a video of a guy
who went through it oh no and it was
super interesting I think we watched
that on the show
was it a while ago or just recently it
was I found it recently when your wife
sees your new height for the first time
five nine the thing about this now she's
not gonna leave him
she loves me finally yeah she she put me
up to this
Jesus Christ the thing about this is
that look house
skinny his leg is because they just put
like a metal plate in here
and
I don't think you can ever live normally
again like I don't think you can run
seems like a terrible or be active your
leg will snap in half
just for a couple inches extra I mean
come on people ah
I'm surprised I thought this was like an
insult thing but if he's like married
and [__] it's so confusing she wanted it
[__] she loves his doll ass down yeah
yeah he's the Walker lots of people are
insecure about this the other guy who
did it was like fit he was he was like
handsome fit he seemed like totally
great he was just a little short he went
from like
he went from like five five to five
eleven
four inches yeah or six inches yeah I
can do math six inches is crazy I know I
thought I thought those surgeries could
only do like an inch or two no no it's
like it's no they can do like three to
six inches you can tell look how
unnatural his leg looks this is like all
well we support gender affirming care
here so
right that's true fair enough I mean he
when it comes down to uh coital uh
Affairs it can't be easy for him
oh
it depends which position probably I
mean if you're on your back but like she
loves his ass though look at her she's
like yeah dude look at this it's tall
you're so hot now she starts feeling her
shoulders and [__] she's like yeah dude
[__] hated you before but now you're
nasty before short loser
oh well you know he said she didn't want
me to do it but supporting me
okay so weird I'll be fair to her
here's the guy
his name has got my knees wait this is
him oh so he's like a massive dude
yeah his handle that rocks got my knees
done yeah that's his thing so wait
reunited with my bro Siff and had to
take an update pick
because that's the guy who wants to
impress in reality
which one is here
the left
oh it says he's six five
he went up to six five
oh in that video the initial video I
think she's five nine yeah right okay so
yeah six five it makes sense he went up
to six five
that's a lot dude come on why'd you do
that
I love that he blurred out his dick I
don't know what this is but it's funny
all right get it brother you're you're
tall now man you're six five King it's
all gonna be different now mm-hmm and
fix your whole life this is the one he
was already kind of tall that's my point
yeah it must have been like six foot
greedy ass
yeah I'd kill to be six foot five nine
and three-fourths or five eleven and
three fours right now he can enjoy our
show
only tall people allowed to watch um
um
okay
interesting
benship he was mad at Blues Clues
oh this is gonna be good
Ben Shapiro he they they cannot not talk
about trans things they're it's they're
so obsessed my God
I mean the daily wire is basically just
the transphobia network it's like they
have one act that they continue to do
yeah they're all in it's it's the
campaign strategy for 2024 so we'll see
how that works out for him
there's like inflation there's much
better things there's so many problems
and we're supposed to care about trans
people should go to Peru and do some
Ayahuasca I think it could help him
hopefully he never comes back
I don't know what happens in the jungle
you just know that some people don't
come back
because they just loved it so much and
they're so connected to Nature and the
Amazon and it just you know yeah
amazingly changed his life that's one
outcome I guess yep
so when we're talking about trans
nonsense apparently okay it's a little
quiet uh Zach
it's so exciting news even the smallest
children in the show are now going to
promote trans nonsense apparently Blues
Clues [__] stop stop you're
doing a segment about Blue's Clues Clues
stop it right now
you stop that [__] right now
okay tell me why Blues Clues is
destroying America apparently they are
now promoting Pride nonsense
apparently they put out what of what
what it was okay first of all trans is
one thing what does he mean Pride
nonsense now we're just writing off the
entire LGBT community
fried nonsense
yeah absolutely
like come on dude chill
graphics this is Circa like 20 21. they
put out Graphics of characters from
Blue's Clues carrying gay pride Flags
one of the Beavers this happened two
years ago wait why is he doing first of
all it doesn't circum in approximately
yeah so what so he doesn't know the date
I mean it's not like ancient times
[Laughter]
2021 A.D just to be clear yeah
um uh June 2021 is where I'm seeing the
episode uh
was uh wait it's not even episode shared
a video on its official YouTube page all
right let's take a look at this
propaganda on Blues Clues has had a Top
surgery
so first of all beavers don't have two
nipples I mean
how does he know that the beaver had a
Top surgery
wait
is this a party is this a AI parody oh
wait what the [__] okay hold on let me
keep watching it's weird that we're now
supposed to talk about Beaver nipples
but that's where we are right no you're
right about you bro first of all I don't
see any nipples on those beavers how
does he know that one's a Top surgery
but apparently beavers trans himself now
I have a little secret review beavers
don't actually do that that's not oh
that was just his fantasy wait
oh he made that he made that up that
conclusion on his own accord so he crew
okay let me watch this again hold on
so first of all beavers don't have two
nipples I mean we're now supposed to
talk about Beaver dimples but that's
where we are nobody's supposed to do
that bro you're the only one talking
about Beaver nipples brothers let's do
that yeah but apparently beavers trans
himself now I have a little secret
review beavers don't actually do that
wait when did he say Top surgery I know
he did first of all beavers has had a
Top surgery okay there you go so he's
just saying because that's what trans
people do
so first of all beavers this looks like
fan art like I don't even know it's real
it's real it's kind of Snopes article
about it nipples it wasn't from an
episode it was from just like a little
pride video that they put out uh at the
beginning of pride month in June 2020
okay nipples but that's where we are as
a society but apparently beavers trans
themselves now I have a little secret
for you beavers don't actually do that
that's not a thing but um according oh
Ben just found out what uh Adam uh
sometimes people use animals to portray
human-like characteristics
don't actually wear clothes right I
don't know I don't know if you need to
know this
what is it called it's called Anna
anamorphic or something because I
remember learning about that it's a name
for it for what sorry when they use when
you give animals human characteristics
anthrope and more anamorphic
anthropomorphic anthropo
anthropomorphic yeah I think I learned
that in like fifth grade
okay Flex he's like oh because you read
like um
you know uh have you read uh Old
MacDonald I mean
is that a book is that a song Old
McDonald's Farm that's a book it's a
Mark Twain novel I haven't read the book
so you know uh the Youtube channel uh
maybe that's why I didn't know yeah yeah
yeah whatever the [__] yeah yeah anybody
by the way Bruce he can't say a lot but
he says he knows how to say e-i-e-i-o
so he just walks around going e-i-e-i-o
e-i-e-i well that's the best that's the
catchiest part of the song Everybody
Knows
Iran knows the EI part what's the
e-i-e-i-o part Ben Shapiro's gonna watch
like uh
uh all uh uh lady in the [__]
okay I just want to tell you my my
children are watching this I just want
to let you know that dogs cannot
actually talk okay I don't want you
getting just crazy ideas that dogs can
talk they can't love either I'll just
have you know there's no evidence that
dogs can love
okay dogs only have dogs have much more
than two nipples I'll have you know that
first of all right now
look at six nipples
[Laughter]
and yes you can milk them if you
approach it in the right way
the people who make Blue's Clues
according to everybody who makes
children's TV these days it is necessary
to push Trans on the kids very very
important
and so that's why you're finding this
sort of stuff in Transformers as we
talked about last week transforming it
on Blues Clues Bob cannot allow your
kids to watch I saw I saw this movie the
other day and they were putting pushing
this trans ideology a semi truck turned
into a giant fighting robot
I was supposed to believe that that's
realistic
that a semi truck can become a giant
fighting robot the technology is way off
on that we're not even close to that
it's a Pure Fantasy
it is necessary to push Trans on the
kids very very important
and so that's why you're finding this
sort of stuff in Transformers as we
talked about last week
Transformers it's in the name bro
um
conspiracy goes way back it goes back to
the 80s that's the best part about this
is actually that his wife is a doctor
his wife yeah he's a doctor
yikes you cannot allow your kids
you can't don't let your kids watch
children TV without pre-screening the
shows don't do okay this band is really
telling parents watch the whole [__]
show before you let them do you not have
a life dude you're gonna sit down and
watch the episode of Blue's Clues
before your kid watches it I mean get a
[__] life dude
you know what I mean
okay I will tell you uh I've cleared
episode one and two of Blue's Clues I
have not yet watched three four but five
is okay as well I watched that last
night
no do not watch episode two or three
until I can make sure that there's no
trans uh propaganda okay
I did find something a little
problematic in the first episode but I'm
gonna let it slide blue for example when
he was turned around I noticed he had
two nipples on his chest only two
nipples
what do you have Top surgery
do it or alternatively go subscribe to
daily wire plus the kids content is
coming you're disgusting we keep asking
when you rumor
dude you're so [__] good content what
dude that is so wrong bro oh my God I
promise I'll let you know as soon as we
have it ready we're gonna be making
great kids content not made to influence
them okay like there's all this garbage
scratch the boys will be boys the girls
will be girls the girls will be pretty
and wear dresses and the guys would be
biggest frog and they'll gonna use
swords and stuff like that yeah
okay can't wait
but it's gonna be amazing I'm sure
that's free screening the content for
you and that way your kids can watch
stuff without worrying about whether a
beaver is going to have
his
her breasts removed or some such
nonsense on Blues Clues yeah that was
totally not even what the [__] is this
contest that was that wasn't that wasn't
mentioned at all that's insane to have
this
as a set topic well there anyway they
can talk about trans issues is a dub for
them yeah dug deep because again two
years ago right yeah what the [__]
they're running out of material man
it also didn't happen at all it didn't
happen two years ago he's just making
[__] up at this point yeah the squirrel
had a Top surgery okay if you read the
lore on the squirrel he had a top and
bottom surgery he was under young he was
underage at the time his parents cleared
off on it okay but uh they got bad
advice from a doctor they said the
squirrel was gonna kill himself if he
didn't get but that wasn't true at all
it was it
uh also did you want to watch the
segment in in question we have it here
the full one
or the the oh okay this is it trans
Beaver let's watch it let's see how
offensive this is roll it wait why did
the screenshot they take look so [__]
up and weird doesn't look that weird
here
all right let me watch the whole thing
um well it has uh music which we
probably can't play so okay by the way
this actually has 4.1 million views and
half dislike so apparently this entered
the culture War
comments turned off
well it's a pride thing overtly so
obviously Blue's Clues Pride Parade
sing-along
[Applause]
[Music]
families uh dogs can't be blue it's time
for a pride parade yeah I'm surprised
that you even got through the whole
premise of the show Doctor communicate
to human beings and they're not bloop uh
dinosaurs are extinct and did not
cohabitate the planet Earth with human
beings particularly this is particularly
ridiculous they died out in Circa 65
million years ago
Circa uh 20 uh Circa last month Circa
yesterday
yeah probably families marching one by
one hurray hurray family has two mommies
indoctrines they love each other so
proudly they all go marching and parade
families marching two by two hurray
hurray look at the bow families marching
two by two hurray this is so far the
family has two daddies they love each
other so proudly they all go marching in
the big parade
killing it
okay so far pretty tame family's
marching three by three hurray hurray
the babies
you know Ben you know if Ben
I'm getting in button territory yeah
careful I'm just I'm just saying that it
better okay you hit the button if you
think I need to well is it working good
we everything's good everything make
sure the bottom let's just skip let's
say if skip it let's just say okay can
you give us like three Clues we'll put
it
any company Danny notebook
oh hold on hold on
let me let me probe this joke lose a
Girl by the way oh we're getting uh a
copyright uh really
[__] dude Never mind take it
down
[__] yeah Jordan's right our month is
way too long laughs
yo you really how can you be for pride
and claim this video a month that's
homophobic as [__] well you're while
you're typing out this horrible thing
that we're gonna tell you not to say
um we actually got a little preview of
The Daily wires uh kids content oh
that's yeah that's appropriate yeah the
Second Amendment is actually enshrined
in the Constitution for a reason I
believe kids should have guns since six
months if not real ones but toys just so
they get used to the idea
I would love to see Ben scadoo into that
video
with cardi B one behind him
okay let me show you a picture if I can
of um
of Ben's car now hold on hold on hold on
okay okay okay
here's a picture of Ben let him cook
oh no let him go
[Music]
hold on we're having a test all right
we're back yeah no that got beat up it
was funny though right it was funny but
yeah no we're not sure
too spicy too spicy for YouTube I was
just saying like maybe I can describe it
I feel it just move on just move on yeah
well as long as you thought it was funny
usually you don't even find them fun in
them like well no I see the humor in the
joke okay
okay okay
hahaha
all right well anyway wow mommy and
daddy's loving each other that's [__]
crazy right now dude
no more of this yeah we're gonna get
blocked all right shut up we get the
idea shout out to Ben Shapiro
he's driving near the the parade and he
might take a detour through it
drive angry you know what I mean
okay
um
where are we let's see but shabibo
oh you like these when we watch these
love the pharah khalidi ones oh yeah
they do good on social
hell yeah buddy
so here's more of uh of pharah who we
love
she is crushing the Alphas
on their own turf here she is
so guys consider a woman going to
parties or even like
here she is I rank that so guys consider
a woman going to parties or even like
having a public Instagram account an act
of infidelity so what do you consider a
loyal woman I would probably have the
password of the Instagram account if you
guys okay hold on hold on can you turn
it up Zach more
turn down on your laptop by chance
uh no it's up all the way I just turned
up the trim a little bit okay go ahead
and try again okay because this is gonna
be good this man said you need a
password or Instagram so guys yeah
that's better at parties or even like
having a public Instagram account an act
of infidelity so what do you consider a
loyal woman I would probably have the
password of the Instagram account if it
got very serious I'd be able to see
every message and she wouldn't
you that how are you gonna deny that's
insecure you're gonna ma these guys they
can't face the truth you're just
insecure you gotta read every message
that she gives and sends you don't trust
her it's crazy it's [__] nuts how do
you even live your life that paranoid
problem with that but women don't want
space for men they're actually in love
with it sure does that type of space go
both ways like we also have your
passwords apparently not no she wouldn't
so how does she bro wait how are you
real wasn't there another one that like
after the same conversation was it the
Freshman fit guys
was it Tate somebody else like had a
whole thing about like
my girls pass that was that Tate was the
one's like I can cheat they can't cheat
right that's biology okay yeah that's
biology right yeah Russian fit did too
they called into that podcast and got
hung up on they all they have like 10
things yeah they all have the same take
so I guess but how are you gonna even be
like a serious person and say that like
come on now you feel unfortunately you
are truly best friends you are
emotionally therefore I also say a lot a
man should be the mountain that a
woman's emotional waves crash into if
you were truly truly giving yourself
away to a man you wouldn't Market on the
internet and I do look at it as
marketing when a woman has her titties
all over the internet I think that's 100
percent
tater tots hello I want to find out who
this is can we do some Ops I want to
figure out who this guy is he seems like
I actually looked into it Justin Waller
Waller who is he he it's like an
underground alpha male I guess uh he's
kind of like a little bit of a [__]
compared to a lot of these other guys
he's more inspirational kind of business
side stuff he doesn't unfortunately go
on this like uh
I think this is him his Instagram bio
reads a public figure father husband
entrepreneur addiction and mental health
Advocate believer in Christ oh Jesus
enters the picture
wait is this the same guy this might not
be the same guy Jesus says is it I can't
tell it is the same guy it does look a
little bit different
Jesus said take thy wife's Instagram
password
if my issue more is when men have
asymmetrical standards yes girl girl
who's not showing her titties on
Instagram but then they're explore Pages
full of Instagram models and they're
liking their posts or they're watching
porn so for me if I found a guy who
wouldn't want me on Instagram and that
was the love of my life I would just
want him to not be on Instagram either
if you want my passwords the same Cuts
both ways and if anything it makes more
sense for the girl to have the guy's
passwords because guys are the first to
stray
uh that was the wrong uh Justin Waller I
found the correct one other audio just
reads I mean it that seemed that bio
very much sounded like it would have
been his bio but no his bio reads uh
hard to catch and never home he sounds
horrible I'm out to lunch baby
I'm out to lunch so sick
the lights on but nobody's home
uh yeah I mean again she's serving but
it's like so obvious that you but it's
like you have to say that to these
people it's stunning it is stunning
here's another one of pharaohs
uh
just take a look
a guy who desires a woman with a low
body count yet he has a high body count
do you have an issue with that of course
it's hype uh why that's such a stupid
question bro
yeah if you [__] tons of people you
should not care your partner's body
count that's insane
100 like I said I think it's your
prerogative to find someone who matches
your values I'm highly selective I want
a partner who's also highly selective I
don't think that maps onto body count
well I just want to be very clear about
this you're looking for a fair situation
but news flash the light world is not
fair that man is going to get up and go
through stress every day and face the
challenges of the world while you have a
pretty cushed life men have always bro
this guy he's what happened to you
can I also say another point it's from
an audio criticism those mics are not on
they're not working that's shotgun
[__] microphone you can't see blogger
awesome [__] microphone are you
serious you don't think they're right
they're on Theory no I mean based off
the fact we had to boost the audio
[__] on the evening this fan has mics
that aren't even set up that's kind of
Epic that takes the fake podcast thing
to the next level without a doubt this
is a real podcast though I'm pretty sure
yeah no yeah but it's like
you need a [__] ton of inputs I doubt
they have that capacity
you know what it's like if you're gonna
[__] 100 women at least could you get 10
mics working you know what I mean
[__] a One mic for every 10 women you
[__] to work spend your time on your job
looking for a fair situation but news
flash the light world is not fair is
going to get up and go through stress
every day and face the challenges of the
world while you have a pretty cush life
and men have always slept with multiple
women it's not fair it's [__] I know
it hurts I know it sucks I know it's not
a good thing to say but it is absolutely
true sure come on man I mean what do you
even say to that you Live's men's lives
are hard women's lives easy
men [__] women
a Kush
bro do you have a period do you even
know what that is
right try doing that for like you know
what I mean [__] God that [__] sucks
bro
trying to find this dude's podcast and
isn't it it's not his it's it's the
whatever podcast it's
um I feel like the guy whether whatever
guy he is just like an instigator he
doesn't believe in any of this [__] he's
just bringing on people and like but he
does this every time yeah yeah
definitely yeah I don't know I don't
like it point was in responsible I mean
it is which is would I have a problem
with the asymmetry of wanting a woman
with a low body count while having a
high one and I would because when I
consider a valid reason for preferring a
partner with a low body count is that
it's better for pair bonding if you
don't have that propensity to seek
novelty you're less likely to stray
people who are more promiscuous they
tend to be more Unfaithful correct that
comes both ways studies do not the
studies clearly show that it is far far
more likely the case with women than men
it does when we're talking about a study
this man is so [__] dumb
this man has never read a study I
guarantee that to you right now
I'm a virgin find a study that says that
women are more likely to cheat is that
what he said or what what does he say
you're less likely to stray people who
are more promiscuous they tend to be
more Unfaithful
studies do not the studies clearly show
that it is far far more likely the case
with women than men it does when we're
talking about virgins we talk about two
virgins yes sure let's stay on topic so
my point is that like guys are seeking
virgins so the reciprocals right but
that would be a guy who's also a virgin
like you just the studies show that men
want to [__] virgins
what are you saying what's the yeah
what's which study was that
comprehensive multinational studies
concluded that men just want to [__]
virgins
right okay uh
-huh you can cite a study that approve
that when both partners are virgins the
pair bonding is more intense correct
okay whatever cool Jesus Christ man
okay Farah khalidi keep it up
the Avengers of misogyny
the only one missing is Rolo Tony Brown
town but I think he's too much of a
douche to even fit here
yo Tristan would be looking more like a
thumb than ever my boy yo
yo we hate women and we don't care who
knows it
foreign
do they not realize they look very goofy
Tristan especially yeah looks like he
was left he's confused he was left in
the dryer yeah a little bit I get what
kind of look they're going for the alpha
like kind of oh yeah strong strong shin
bone whatever but it just they're like
it's like a meta version of that it just
looks like a meme yeah I don't know who
this guy is but he is not it's not
working for him it is not happening for
you brother get him out of there dude
get the [__] up why is he sagging his
white
skinny jeans it's like not working
brother pull them up he's just pulling
the whole [__] crew down dude dude
seriously you're only as strong as
you'll ever think this is a weak ass
link also that collar of suit come on
bro also Tate looks like Joe beta in
this photo yeah why stayed so far back
in little looking he's he's being a
Wallflower
that could be Tate's dad
isn't his dad black yeah yeah I'm just
saying it for the meme oh okay thank you
yeah very good it does look weird a few
of the photos I thought were
Photoshopped it looks like Tate's not
even actually there like this one right
here wait what
what the [__] is going on here
so this is the same photo but now
there's another mystery guy tacked on
wait no but that
but that's the same oh that same photo
did they just they just crop them out no
no I crop I cropped it out when I sent
it because I know who the [__] is so
who's this look at the next photo that
just got sent okay you know those AI
tools where you can like extend the
image to the left and it generates
another part it looks like that guy just
got generated so here are these shoes
now is this one it's not the same photo
they're just standing in the exact same
they have one I got one pose bro but
yeah but ignoring that other photo just
on its own it kind of looks like I don't
know I feel like there's a different
it's weird I don't know let me see here
yeah his face is different oriented but
it's kind of you know these guys with
the same pose they're in the mirror
practicing they're in the same pose both
of them like I'm sorry dude that's
insecure Brothers
just be yourself yeah man from my good
side
be yourself this guy's my fave man he
really is Ultimate douche unlocked I
want to learn more about him
Rolo Tony is like bro you need to retire
you're not on their league bro
I think Rolo is on the outs from that
whole world right I think they're all
turning on him because he's a loser yeah
good he is what are you afraid of Ian
Tristan be looking like
he'd be looking kind of
uncomfortable in his own skin
like the [__]
alien from Men In Black that guy's face
is Sinister okay this dude only takes
profile shots where his face is facing
the camera his eyes are so scary in this
photo he also takes booty pics of
himself too oh really
see that
oh my god dude he's got Caked Up
yo it's snack time in the gym God damn
bro I thought sugar wasn't allowed in
the gym
[Music]
how you gonna cut bringing that kind of
cake in there for everyone to eat
that's him
well you did not have to wear pants that
tight
damn [__]
little [__] skank what a little [__]
skank going around the gym all Caked Up
like that why are you marketing yourself
on Instagram like that
gross I need your password yeah hand it
over
yeah these guys are losers it's
endlessly entertaining
um let's see a dubs called in on
Wednesday I have a
special uh I don't know if I'll just
drop it
I've got a fun episode of planned on
Wednesday
yeah
what are you talking about I'll type it
and you tell me if I should just
I think it's better just to wait
I think we might have mentioned it no we
definitely didn't no we didn't I know
what I'm talking about he's not talking
about that there's a lot going on on
Wednesdays
on Wednesday yeah it's gonna be good
it's gonna be good
we're making progress there on the back
end we got surprises Galore this week
don't skip a week don't skip an episode
baby
surprise us throughout
all right so let's let's see what we've
got here then we can decide which
Stories We want to hit three hours yeah
so let's see what we want to hit then
with our limited time we've got uh
Charlie responds
[Music]
we've got yeah you know that's probably
the easiest sure well we've got a tick
tock Deep dive that I think that needs
more time I I'd say Charlie if we're
gonna do Charlie that's easy let me just
watch one so I can get a taste for what
we're dealing with yeah oh this guy he's
a he's a comedian yeah he's a comedian
we like him we've got YouTuber Sloan had
Channel struck by Scooter Braun
the [__] interesting oh he's
bullshitting how does he know his
Scooter Braun
well this
I'm being silenced as he posts a video
I know a lot of you guys wanted to hear
a life of date and I wish I had better
news but today I woke up and I had
another strike on my channel if you guys
don't know what a YouTube story is oh oh
no this guy's a good guy I know him yeah
I remember I I connected with him yeah
we yeah he uh got an ace family letter
remember oh yeah I think I put him in
touch with my peeps you did I talked to
him at imran's birthday and he was
saying thank you so much yeah he's a
really nice guy of course nice but the
what the [__] Scooter Braun like
actually pretty much the worst thing
that can happen to your channel and I
got a second one it wasn't long ago that
I received a strike on my channel for
video related to Demi Moore and now I'm
receiving one because Scooter Braun is
trying to silence me so let me let me
give you guys some backstory and then
we'll get into how I've been doing and
just you know posted about Scooter Braun
and Taylor Swift's relationship owned by
him there's no reason why that video
should have been taken down completely
fair use I used a bunch of I just want
to know who's it owned by
wait who's Scooter Brown
he's like this uh super powerful it said
content removed by Scooter Braun LLC yo
that's crazy what a psycho all over
taking [__] down and off the internet I
can't believe he would actually put his
name on that what a dumbass
huh so this guy he's like a high power
music producer he's a manager he manages
he's got a big beef with paper Ariana
Grande Madison Beer people like that he
bought like all of Taylor Swift's
yes he is screaming license and then she
had to re-record all of her music yeah
Taylor's version is because of Scooter
Braun I love that she did that me too I
would do that she's a slay you would do
that you know what I mean Ethan's
version today we were talking about when
we found out that bbtv saw all the money
we're actually talking about
re-recording about 300 episodes yeah
that's what I would do like word for
word yep I would do it
the videos that I there's the most
played part they're all over on the
internet he didn't go and pull their
video but people love to go and pick on
me for you know whatever reason
alone trying my best to you know start a
new routine
um except the breakup and just kind of
move on and work and it's been really
difficult I've been posting videos but
I've not I don't know why that was the
most watched part but okay slow and our
heart goes out to you if you need help
let me know
[__] Scooter Braun [__] scooter Ron
dumbass
uh Tick Tock Deep dive on Timon idiot
[__]
another god-loving Alpha dude Timon
Creek
yeah so this is I sort of started on
this on that episode where we were
switching roles but I feel like you
would get really good commentary on it
and we weren't really watching it oh
this guy yo this video is [__] rules
yes have you seen this yo this is my one
of the best videos I think I saw this
natively on my Instagram reels and I was
like yo that [__] is awesome check
this out this is the most inspirational
[__] you are ever gonna see let's go out
this weekend there's a crazy event
happening there'll be a ton of chicks
let's just go have fun and let go a
little sounds good yeah that ain't my
kind of fun oh you know what wait hold
on hold on
the video I saw it stopped after this
[Laughter]
this video was a virus for me because
once I had this all of my feeds are this
guy all right let me see what he's
actually about let me see yeah that
ain't my kind of fun oh you know what's
fun for me waking up early hitting the
gym spending time with my Creator
building their life I desire and more
importantly becoming a better version of
myself you can still kick it with your
friends dog it's not that serious
oh you kick it with your creator
I don't need friends I kick it with my
creator
bro chill every damn day so if your kind
of fun is getting you and you know
what's interesting this camera is on a
tripod he's kicking it with his creator
right now yeah ain't no he doesn't work
with no friends you don't believe it I
don't have time for friends I have no
friends no loved ones
that's the alpha mindset nobody likes me
yeah
he said his parents house in front of
his parents house in the middle of the
street
I'll kick it with my Creator right now
bro I ain't got time
[__] faced over the weekend that's cool
but we don't do that over here we're
focused on God goals and growth who's we
there's no one there it's a welcoming
video for a cult
bro don't focus on God so much he's
there you know I mean he's not going
anywhere
imagine he has to re-record because
there's a car coming
it's funny I don't have time for hanging
out with friends but you're in the
middle of the street with the tripod
you're miked up and you're moving
probably like you're playing pickup
basketball every time someone drives by
no no no he's there with God God
prevents cars from yeah driving down the
street God's directing traffic here is
another one let's check it out I love
him I'm not single because Dodgers okay
hmm
conduct God do anything good to get them
a World Series I mean what's going on
here I'm not single because I can't get
with someone
I'm single because every time I focus on
somebody they show me exactly what I'm
better off
[Music]
okay dude
also I'll say we have the music removed
from these there's music in the
background the originals and it makes it
a lot more epic yeah these girls are
gross she's playing better off alone I
don't know
oh my goodness man
do you think you'd think she when he
thinks about God he jerks off sometimes
yeah like let's be real well he's
probably apologizing I'm so sorry God's
plan yeah if God God is his homie he's
there he does everything for him he's
invested in God sometimes he's got to
slip into his mind when he jerks off
right big powerful arms probably big
shoulders big strong hands
literally
fat Godly God like [__] as the father of
the son
it's just a it's like a three DP on him
with the father The Ghost and the sun
everybody's just going to town on him
good ass time the father of the son the
Holy Spirit are all packing
oh yeah
they're spit roasting him
oh my God
that's a good ass time right there amen
Jesus this is a good I love this guy
trust in God's plan okay
tell me
Dear God
it's not easy
but I promise you I won't give up
I have no idea what's happening in my
life just give up bro I don't know
what's going on I don't know where I am
so lost I'm so confused
I'm just give up dude
oh is this music it's fine we've removed
it we checked it it's all good okay cool
we'll trust you
even though I don't know where you're
taking me
I do know
that you got me
some what me to my kidnapper he's a pair
in the back of the van to my kidnappers
dude this is
drama dumping this is trauma so weird so
weird how his shirt says gift gifted
like a gift gift not easy I'm just
thank you
he's like God
my life is [__] at travesty
nobody loves me I never go out I'm a
little utterly and
purely alone
I'm confused I don't know where my
life's going but I know you got me
thank you but thank you for putting
thank you for making me friendless yes
maidenless
easy made and let's lose her ass this
guy's virgin For Sure Shot One Give Up
by choice of course I have no idea
what's happening in my life right now
can you cut that I love that
I mean this guy has lost like I don't
think I've ever known anyone that lost
I don't know anything that's going on in
my life right I don't even know my own
name
I think I have amnesia
I still trust you
even though I don't know where you're
taking me are you wearing this [__]
New York Hat do you remember wearing the
Dodgers thing
no no offense love
because this guy's pretty interesting
God is essential in a relationship
no God is my relationship bro did you
not hear what I just said it's a
three-peat with the Holy Trinity
um
I take them one at a time
the next time you try for a relationship
just remember if it's outside the love
of God it isn't love at all
if God isn't in the relationship it
won't work out God should be the sense
of your career the center of yours by
his thesis all atheist
relationships end in divorce every
single one
yeah all things are possible with God I
feel like that's disprovable
mm-hmm
with minimal effort you know won't work
out that's true God should be the Saints
of North Korea the center of your
relationship the Saints of your own and
the center of your life
oh he definitely jerks off and thinks
about God
weird [__] man
my loved ones never mess with my loved
ones uh-oh but you have loved ones
loser yes right hand focusing on
yourself mess with me
I'll let Karma do its job
but the ones I love totally heretical
dude I'll become comma what why are you
talking about Karma that is not
do people watch God
they have to yeah no I'm sorry yes he is
like super loved in his comments no yeah
and what's amazing about him is every
video is a banger you don't get these
guys often mm-hmm
do its job
why is it in his pocket so deep
like have you ever put your pocket that
deep you know yeah you know what that
means it's [__] jammed in there
there's some real-time uh masking if you
know what I mean he's getting all horned
up talking about God I know what you
mean by Karma nope
mess with me
I'll let Karma do its job
but most of the ones I love
I'll become Karma okay oh
whoa okay taken Liam Nielsen
what are you gonna do [__]
pray against me you're gonna pray
against me
all right that was cool I mean that's
about it
he has a coaching company called school
for CEOs
check this out
there's nothing God loved more than
getting rich okay I mean what the this
is not giving me professional video what
the hell
like a clothing company for
five-year-olds
foreign
okay who doesn't want to go to a school
that's spelled wrong in the name schools
for CEOs how he pronounces it school
school
let's see acceleration cool let's watch
this video in this video I'm going to
provide you with an overview of what my
social media coaching program in sales
so you know exactly what you're getting
yourself into so this program can I take
this course one is acceptable I'll take
it for a second material yeah I love
that [__] okay let's not like five
thousand dollars just because I know
probably you already said yes probably
just drop Drop Shipping Drop Shipping
you all Drop Shipping he just drop ships
you a Hustler's University course so
I'll start off by running through
accelerator and yeah go for it baby this
is this is totally who's uh buying his
course by the way
I knew when I saw this logo I was
destined for great things
by the way the spacing is weird it's
inconsistent like look at the space
between the K and the o
and then the O's are touching but then
the L and O is closer
is this is weird right cam horrible
horrible kerning
horrible kerning School
you look like a slob idiot dumbass like
an idiot loser God's not gonna [__] you
bro
how how many times how many different
times I have to put that he's not gonna
[__] you
Star Wars Hotel already closed down
after one year of opening we called that
didn't we that's actually what a
disaster
I mean they must have spent a whole lot
of money on this thing yeah
and they're just they just like nah
they probably can't get enough people
that want to spend five grand to sleep
in a hole in the wall yeah there's no
windows it sounded really really dumb
well rest in peace
ah yeah something bro get out of here
this [__] y'all are trying to even make
it look fun it looks dumb as hell hold
on I was watching a video
of the actual experience itself and it
looks way too overwhelming let me drop
this and just skip around okay I'm
really interested to see this actually
just skip around you'll see like they
have like you know after a long day at
the park you probably want to chill oh
yeah you don't want to like be on all
the time this is just like a weird um
Star Wars Galactic star Cruiser so
should I just skip around yeah just skip
around to get an idea
all right so we're walking into one of
the rooms on the galactic star Cruiser
here cozy
we've got the data pad here which we'll
show you a little bit more of it there's
no TV as you guys know TV doesn't exist
information
got our porthole out looking out into
space
yeah you're in a you're in a [__]
windowless room
that's a tiniest bunk over there man
that is straight up hostile living
orange under there
like I could see it being fun if you're
a super hardcore Star Wars fan or
whatever but I I don't think it's worth
the five grand price of admission right
but the end of the day you're still live
sleeping in like a cot in the wall yeah
I mean I assume there's stuff to do
you're not spending that much time in
your room right like no if you keep
skipping around you'll see they do like
here's the weird [__] in the lobby in
the lobby they've got you can play Pong
cool oh there's a ton of people there oh
[__] this looks like mine hell on Earth
everyone's filming and [__] I'm just
trying to go to my room
[Applause]
all right oh you guys are having too
much fun this place is closed down fun
is over
what the [__]
are you just getting screamed at
getting arrested getting arrested by a
stormtrooper they beat you
that's so funny I
dude I'm trying to find out what time to
pull
this is the most watched part here let's
see also there's not like a little kid
in sight these are all adults right yeah
that happens very often with these kind
of like Star Wars things it just gets
gay tilted by old nerds
by young people yeah we're under attack
bro they're gonna sleep here
it's not a drill you guys
I swear it's not a drill
oh no it's Kyle
kayaking people up
there yes enough
oh [__] I want to see him take someone's
parents scare the [__] out of some kid
you think he takes his shirt off
kylo Ren you [__] my mom
all right yeah that's pretty weird it's
pretty wild damn this okay you know it's
not for me I could say that
I can say that not for a lot of people
shutting down it wasn't for me it wasn't
anything shows up in the hallway leading
into your room you just wake up in the
middle of night and this is standing
over your bed Hey kid
he is stacked though you can't take that
away from me he's so wide he's stacked
very wide man oh yeah he was in the army
or something
yeah he doesn't get all some people are
still out just thinking that he exists
in the wrong aspect ratio
right you got the scratch get out some
people are still out there thinking that
hooking up with a bunch of random people
is a flex
my Kings and my Queens hear me outs
hooking up with someone who is
accessible to everyone will never be a
flex a real Flex is having one loyal
god-loving person who nobody else can
touch
version
hear me now he literally does like
theology I mean our people
boy that guy all right all right
actually here let me pull up his um
Instagram I want to see what his
engagement is like oh he has seven
almost eight hundred thousand followers
are you
you know this guy has Star Wars Lighting
in all of his videos one million likes
bro don't say that to me right now again
I'm not ready for that I'm not ready for
that and I'm not ready for this
not ready to hear that
okay let's see one million likes on
video I bought extremely nice kind
loving people I don't know if we can
yeah we haven't pre-checked it ah shame
but like the comments are insane like
very supportive
God is great
but God did it all
good job
wait I'm confused because that one had a
million likes but none of his videos
have over a million views
I'll get that or I guess it wasn't a
real it was just an upload yeah
okay
um so rest in peace to the Star Wars
Hotel tragic tragic package totals six
thousand dollars a night for a family
actually despite the price the hotel
garnished some of the Park's highest
ever guest satisfaction rating
uh this was worked on for six years
and closed after 15 months damn
they said about it uh Star Wars Galactic
star Cruiser is one of our most creative
projects ever and has been praised by
our guests and recognized for setting a
new bar of innovation immersion this
premium Boutique experience gave us the
opportunity to try new things on a
smaller scale of 100 rooms as we prepare
for its final voyage we will take what
we've learned to create future
experiences that can reach more of our
guests and fans wow that is really a
disaster if they're closing it that soon
there it is
we have Ezra Miller and Charlie so we
can call it or we can do one of those uh
we're at 308. that's really let's save
some juice you gotta save the juice you
gotta ration the juice sometimes I mean
what can I even really say about the
Charlie thing though you know what the
Charlie thing perfect see you next
Tuesday content for tomorrow perfect
true is that actually true that's
actually true right yeah
but now that I'm glancing over this oh
thank you Cam uh I was right about him
being in the wrong aspect ratio cam just
did a little correction this is what he
actually looked like in real man before
the error in the editing so yeah his mom
was a Roblox
all right well guys thanks for watching
uh tomorrow
we I will be going live for members on
see you next Tuesday thank you to all of
our beautiful members who support the
show you guys do so much for us and I'm
happy to be there tomorrow for you guys
at three o'clock and on Wednesday I hope
you guys join us I've got a fun
episode planned a little bit juicy
[Music]
in nature
and uh well have a great night guys uh
thank you for being here
see you tomorrow members and everybody
else Wednesday
[Music]
[Applause]